You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
你知道的，你的眼睛承受了很多。每天看书、在昏暗光线下看书、盯着屏幕的时间太长，这情况我经常遇到。开车时阳光刺眼。甚至夜间开车也会导致眼部疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛承受了很大的压力。因此，通过定期的眼科检查来照顾它们并监测眼部健康非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，价格低至 99 美元起，包含 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部及健康状况。要寻找离您最近的分店并预约含
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.capsavers. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi.
OCT 扫描且价格 99 美元起的眼科检查，请访问 specsavers.capsavers。眼科检查由独立的眼科验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是《办公室女孩 6.0》。你好。嗨。
Let's tell everybody what we're doing today because this is exciting. I'm so excited about it. We watched the Hot Girl Peacock Superfan episode. So much extra stuff. So much extra stuff. You know, we went into our mailbag and you all suggested that we watch and break down some of these Peacock Superfan. episodes. There are some people who don't even know these exist. I know. And they're so good. They are such a labor of love of our dear friend Dave Rogers. And I'm so glad we're finally watching them.
让我们告诉大家我们今天要做什么，因为这太令人兴奋了。我对此兴奋不已。我们观看了“辣妹”孔雀超级粉丝集。里面有超级多的额外内容。超级多的额外内容。你知道的，我们翻看收件箱，你们所有人都建议我们观看并剖析这些孔雀超级粉丝剧集。有些人甚至不知道这些的存在。我懂的。而且它们太棒了。它们是我们亲爱的朋友戴夫·罗杰斯的倾心之作。我很高兴我们终于在看它们了。
Yeah. So you know, we broke down Hot Girl before in our original rewatch, but there are added scenes. And we also found so many more things that we could talk about. Well, Jenna, are you going to do a summary? Are you doing fast facts? What's happening? I really sad. with that question, Angela, in planning this episode. Yeah. I'm going to do a title. Okay. Is it hot girl?
是的。所以你知道，我们之前在最初的重看中剖析过《辣妹》，但里面有新增的场景。而且我们还发现了更多可以讨论的事情。嗯，珍娜，你要做个总结吗？你要讲快讯吗？怎么回事？对于这个问题，安吉拉，我在规划这一集时感到很难过。是的。我要说个标题。好的。是《辣妹》吗？
Just curious. I'm going to say this. Okay. Season one, episode six. All accurate. Written by Mindy Kaling. Directed by Amy Heckerling. Yes.
只是好奇。我要这么说。好吧。第一季，第六集。全部准确。明迪·卡林编剧。艾米·海克林导演。是的。
I'm going to give you a summary. Okay. I'm not going to give you any fast facts, though. Okay. I'm not going to, you know. I have to decide at a certain point. You've drawn a line. And it ends here.
我要给你一个总结。好的。不过，我不会给你任何快讯。好吧。我不会，你知道的。我必须在某个时刻做出决定。你已经划清了界限。而它到此为止。
Okay. All right. You heard it. But here's your summary because I couldn't give that up. Okay. The appearance of an attractive purse saleswoman sparks a romantic rivalry between Michael, Dwight, and Jim and causes Pam to examine her own feelings. Okay. Okay.
好吧。好的。你听到了。但这是你的总结，因为我舍不得放弃这个。好的。一个迷人的皮包女销售员的出现，引发了迈克尔、德怀特和吉姆之间的浪漫竞争，并促使帕姆审视自己的真实感受。好吧。好吧。
Now, I'm not going to leave you hanging here in the Top of Show. We did promise we would give Top of Show shares, and I've got a big one for you. Okay. In our original breakdown of this episode, we mentioned that Amy Adams, who stars as the purse girl, Katie, was Mindy Kaling's first choice for the role. But what we didn't share was that Amy Adams was not the first person cast in the role. Nope. We originally shot Hot Girl. for an entire day with a completely different actress in the role of Katie.
现在，我不会把你们悬在节目开场的这个悬念里。我们确实承诺过会给出节目开场的分享，我有一个重磅分享要带给你。好的。在我们最初对这一集的剖析中，我们提到饰演皮包女孩凯蒂的艾米·亚当斯是明迪·卡林饰演这个角色的首选。但我们没有分享的是，艾米·亚当斯并不是最初被选定饰演这个角色的人。没有。我们最初拍摄《辣妹》时，整整花了一天时间，由一个完全不同的女演员来饰演凯蒂。
And unfortunately, she just wasn't quite right for the role. They had to let her go. We replaced her with Amy. And it's so funny because in our original breakdown, we talk about how when Amy was shooting with us, she told us a story about how she had just been fired from a job when we were all on set together. It's such a common thing in the business. it's almost like a rite of passage.
不幸的是，她实在不太适合这个角色。他们不得不让她离开。我们用艾米替换了她。太有趣了，因为在我们最初的剖析中，我们谈到当艾米和我们一起拍戏时，她给我们讲了一个故事，说当我们都在片场时，她刚被一份工作解雇。这在这一行里太常见了。这几乎就像是一种成人礼。
It is. And I actually wrote about it in my book, the actor's life, because while I was writing my book, I got fired from a show and I share all about it in my book. But I also did some research and I thought you might enjoy some of these tidbits. Okay. For example, did you know that Lisa Kudrow was originally cast as Roz in the pilot for Frazier? No. Mm-hmm.
确实如此。我实际上在我的书《演员的生活》中写过这件事，因为当我在写书时，我被一部剧解雇了，我在书中分享了所有关于这的事。但我也做了一些研究，我想你可能会喜欢这些花絮。好的。例如，你知道丽莎·库卓最初在《欢乐一家亲》试播集中被选为罗兹吗？不知道。嗯哼。
Yes. And Ray Romano was originally cast as the handyman in news radio. Really? And he was let go. And Bob Odenkirk was supposed to play Nathan on Will & Grace, but he was let go and replaced with Woody Harrelson. Mm-hmm. Well, you know, it just sometimes comes down to so many things that are outside your control. Mm-hmm.
是的。雷·罗马诺最初在《新闻电台》中被选为杂工。真的吗？他被解雇了。鲍勃·奥登科克本应在《威尔和格蕾丝》中饰演内森，但他被解雇了，由伍迪·哈里森取代。嗯哼。好吧，你知道，这有时归结为许多超出你控制的事情。嗯哼。
And I remember when Amy came on the set, she was so seamlessly Katie. Yeah. She improvises a lot, you guys. We'll get to it. But a lot of her improvs make it in. She just knew who this woman was. Well, Allison Jones shared with us that Amy Adams was everybody's first choice for Katie the purse girl. But there was this concern that Amy and I looked too similar. And I guess one of the writers even said, I'm sorry, we can't cast her. She's like Jenna 2.0. And so they got cold feet and they cast someone else. But when it didn't. work out, they decided to cast Amy and just lean into the fact that she and I looked similar because that wasn't the idea behind the role at first. That was not part of the conception of Katie the purse girl. And then that is why they added that line. She's like Pam 6.0, which is just so amazing because that writer had said it up in the writer's room. Yeah. Well, Jenna, I have a little something to share at Top of Show. Please. So, You know, I went back to the DVDs for this episode to rewatch the original and compare it to the superfan episode.
我记得当艾米来到片场时，她如此天衣无缝地就是凯蒂。是的。她即兴发挥了很多，伙计们。我们会讲到的。但她的很多即兴发挥都被保留了下来。她只是知道这个女人是谁。嗯，艾莉森·琼斯跟我们分享说，艾米·亚当斯是每个人饰演凯蒂这个皮包女孩的首选。但当时有人担心我和艾米长得太像了。我想其中一个编剧甚至说过，抱歉，我们不能选她。她就像是 2.0 版本的珍娜。所以他们退缩了，选了别人。但当事情没有成功时，他们决定选择艾米，并顺应这样一个事实：我和她长得很像，因为这最初并不是这个角色的创作初衷。这并不是构思皮包女孩凯蒂的一部分。然后这就是为什么他们加了那句台词。她就像 6.0 版本的帕姆，这简直太棒了，因为那个编剧在编剧室里说过这话。是的。嗯，珍娜，我在节目开场时有一点小事要分享。请说。所以，你知道，我为了这一集回看了 DVD，重温原版并将其与超级粉丝集进行比较。
And I forgot how much the DVDs themselves evolved as the show went on, just in what they included and the look of them. For example, in this season one disc, when you click on an episode, there is a picture and an episode summary. So for Hot Girl on the screen, there's a picture of Dwight and Katie in the conference room. And then on what looks like to be like a lined piece of notebook paper is the following. Is this their summary? Yes. Oh. What?
我忘了随着剧集的播出，DVD 本身发生了多大的变化，仅仅是它们包含的内容和外观方面。例如，在这个第一季的碟片中，当你点击某一集时，会有一张图片和一集剧情简介。所以在屏幕上的《辣妹》那一集，有一张德怀特和凯蒂在会议室的图片。然后在一个看起来像带横线的笔记本纸上的内容如下。这是他们的总结吗？是的。哦。什么？
That's probably going to be better than that. No, it's not. Stop it. Okay. Stop that. This is what it says. Hot Girl Air Date, semicolon, 4-2605. Okay.
那可能比那个要好。不，它不好。停下。好吧。住手。这就是它上面写的。辣妹播出日期，分号，4-26-05。好的。
And then it says episode summary. The blundering men of Dundermifflin vie for the attention of an attractive woman who appears at the office trying to sell purses. Oh, I think my summary was better. Well, actually. Anyway, there you go. Worried for nothing. There you go.
然后上面写着剧情简介。邓德米夫林的笨拙男人们为了争夺一个来到办公室试图卖包的迷人女性的注意力而展开竞争。哦，我觉得我的总结更好。嗯，实际上。无论如何，就是这样。白担心一场。就是这样。
That is what it says about this episode on the original DVDs. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will break down this super fan episode of Hot Girl. And we have lots of fun new stuff. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not. not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Yeah. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine.
这就是原版 DVD 上关于这一集的介绍。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下？当我们回来时，我们将剖析这集《辣妹》的超级粉丝版。我们有很多有趣的新东西。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，仅仅因为这是新的一年，并不意味着你必须成为一个崭新的自己。但也许你想成为一个负担较少、思绪更清晰的自己。是的。不是一个完全崭新的自己，但也许就像你想磨炼自己。你想完善自己。
Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down. What might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Because those really just add up. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. BetterHelp therapists can help.
是的。我喜欢这个。完善。嗯，疗法可以帮助更轻松地识别是什么在拖累你。什么可能在阻碍你。你可以更好地理解自己的人际关系、你的动力、你的情绪。我正试图放下对小事的焦虑。因为那些真的会累加起来。而且一切都会好起来的。嗯，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。BetterHelp 的治疗师可以提供帮助。
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-elp.com slash office ladies. We are back and we kick things off with the same scene you would have seen in the broadcast episode. Michael is sticking some pencils in his computer keyboard.
拥有超过 3 万名治疗师，BetterHelp 是全球最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供过服务。BetterHelp 让你可以轻松地在网上与合格的治疗师进行匹配。注册并在 BetterHelp.com slash office ladies 获取 9. 折优惠。那是 better, h-elp.com slash office ladies。我们回来了，我们从你会看到的与广播版中相同的场景开始了。迈克尔正在把一些铅笔插进他的电脑键盘里。
He looks like he's, I don't know, bored. He's not working. Nope. And then you come to realize Jan is on speakerphone. Yeah. She and Alan have created a. an incentive program to increase sales. And at the end of the month, Michael can reward the top seller in the office with a prize worth up to $1,000. Yeah. And he says, do I get to decide what that $1,000
他看起来，我不知道，很无聊。他没有在工作。没有。然后你就会意识到简正在免提通话中。是的。她和艾伦制定了一项奖励计划来提高销售额。在月底，迈克尔可以用价值高达 1000 美元的奖品奖励办公室里的销售冠军。是的。他说，我能决定这 1000 美元
is spent on? And she's like, sure. Yeah. And he's like, Jan. Mistake. Yes. And he also wants to know, you know, if you're not still currently in sales, but maybe if you used to be in sale. And she's like, No, Michael, you're not eligible to win. And then next up, we have an added scene, which is so good. Oh, my gosh. I loved it so much. We have Amy Adams arriving in the office as Katie. Yes, Jenna, I thought we should hear how it was described in the shooting draft.
花在什么上面吗？她说，当然。是的。他说，简。犯错了。是的。他还想知道，如果你目前不再从事销售工作，但如果你以前做过销售。她说，不，迈克尔，你没有资格获奖。接下来，我们有一个新增的场景，太棒了。哦，天哪。我太喜欢了。我们看到艾米·亚当斯作为凯蒂来到办公室。是的，珍娜，我觉得我们应该听听剧本拍摄初稿中是怎么描述的。
Great. Interior Office Open Area Day. Meredith is working on a crossword. We hear the door open and Meredith is working on a crossword. Yes, what it says. we hear the door open and whip over to catch Katie, an attractive young woman, enters the office and approaches Pam. When we pan back, we see the heads of men in the office perk up to check her out.
太好了。内景。办公室开阔区。白天。梅雷迪思正在做填字游戏。我们听到门开了，梅雷迪思正在做填字游戏。是的，上面是这么写的。我们听到门开了，镜头一转捕捉到凯蒂，一个年轻迷人的女性走进办公室走向帕姆。当我们把镜头摇回来时，我们看到办公室里男人们的头都抬起来打量她。
Katie is showing Angela some purses from a big duffel. And you guys, the supersized episode shows all the men stopping to look over. I took a screen grab. Literally all the dudes have made some reason to be in the bullpen in the back of the scene. Creed is standing right by the conference room door. Kevin is by the supply shelf. Ryan is next to Phyllis. Toby is by the water cooler. Stanley is really leaning up to look from his desk. Oscar is down on one knee digging through a box by Dwight's desk. Jim is at his desk. And Devin is on his knees at the end of Stanley and Phyllis's desk. All these dudes are watching Katie at front reception as she is trying to sell Pam and Angela. These, these ladies, little purses. At one point, she holds up this little red purse to Pam, and she's like, this color looks really good on you. This is really great for you. Lady, that's the color you say looks really good on me. It made me laugh out loud. You do look really good in that color.
凯蒂正从一个大行李袋里拿出品牌各异的包包给安吉拉看。伙计们，加长版剧集显示所有的男人们都停下来张望。我截了图。字面意思上，所有的老哥都找了某种理由来到场景后面的公用办公区。克里德正站在会议室门边。凯文在储物架旁。瑞恩在菲利斯旁边。托比在饮水机旁。斯坦利正极力从办公桌旁探身张望。奥斯卡单膝跪地在德怀特办公桌旁的一个箱子里翻找。吉姆在自己的办公桌前。德文正跪在斯坦利和菲利斯办公桌的尽头。所有这些老哥都在前台看着凯蒂，当时她正试图向帕姆和安吉拉推销。这些，这些女士们，小包包。有一度，她举起这个小红包给帕姆看，她说，这个颜色真的很适合你。这个对你来说真的很棒。大姐，这就是你说看起来真的很适合我的颜色。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。你穿那个颜色确实很好看。
So here's the thing. I thought we should hear this scene. Yeah. It's really fun. And Amy Adams, she's selling stuff. All right, let's listen. Hi. Hi. Hi. How are you? Okay. Good. I'm Kate. Hi. Hi. Nice to meet you. What's your name? Pam? Hi, nice to meet you, Pam. Let me ask you a question. Do you read a lot of fashion magazines? Because you look really fashion forward. And I just wanted to let you know, hi, how are you? I have a great opportunity today to get in on some of the newest styles. Because I know with your working hours, you don't really probably have a chance to go to the mall very often. So what I have to offer you today is some excellent purses. And if I could just have a space to set up,
所以事情是这样的。我觉得我们应该听听这个场景。是的。真的很有趣。而且艾米·亚当斯，她在推销东西。好了，我们听听吧。嗨。嗨。嗨。你好吗？好的。很好。我是凯特。嗨。嗨。很高兴认识你。你叫什么名字？帕姆？嗨，很高兴认识你，帕姆。我问你一个问题。你经常读时尚杂志吗？因为你看上去真的很前卫。我只是想让你知道，嗨，你好吗？我今天有个绝佳的机会，可以接触到一些最新款式的包包。因为我知道以你的工作时间，你可能真的没有机会经常去商场。所以我今天能为你提供的是一些极好的包包。如果我能有个地方摆摊，
maybe show you what I have and some of your other um here feel that um yeah it really brightens you yeah do you think that gives her a nice color uh i don't um no i really it really suits you um i've got uh faux leather i have some really great fakes you wouldn't even be able to tell the difference i don't want to just like all the movie stars i don't want to interrupt you um sorry um we don't usually allow solicitors in the office well i'm actually uh selling purses right i i'm No, that's what I mean. I can't, I'm just the receptionist. I can't authorize you to, like, come in and set up or anything.
也许可以展示一下我有的东西还有你们其他的呃摸摸那个呃是的它真的让你显得很有生气是的你觉得这给她带来了一个好脸色吗呃我不觉得不，我真的它真的很适合你呃我有呃人造皮革我有一些非常棒的假货你甚至分不清真假我不想像所有的电影明星那样我不想打扰你呃抱歉呃我们通常不允许推销员进办公室好吧我其实是呃在卖包对呀我
Okay, is there somebody that I could talk to? Like, who would authorize? Is that you? I love it. She turns to you, Angela. She's like, who would authorize? Is that you? It's like, you're like, no.
不，我是那个意思。我不能，我只是个前台。我无权授权你，呃，进来摆摊或者什么的。
No. My favorite line is when she says, I have some really great fakes. You won't even be able to tell the difference. Yes. All right. Fan question from Jenna F in Los Angeles. Jenna F remembers that a lot of this scene was improvised. Angela, can you confirm?
好吧，有没有我可以谈谈的人？比如，谁有权授权？是你吗？我太喜欢了。她转向你，安吉拉。她说，谁有权授权？是你吗？就像是，你回答说，不。
Absolutely can confirm. Literally, all it says in the shooting draft is that Katie is showing Angela some purses from a big duffel. And then Pam does go to Michael's office. Yeah. And the only dialogue that is scripted is this. Katie's showing Angela some purses from a big duffel says, that one is hand embroidered. Angela says there's a smudge on it. And then that's when Pam and Michael entered Dwight tagging along behind them.
不。我最喜欢的一句台词是当她说，我有一些非常棒的假货。你甚至分不清真假。是的。好的。洛杉矶珍娜·F的粉丝提问。珍娜·F 记得这个场景很多都是即兴发挥的。安吉拉，你能证实一下吗？
So Amy Adams really improvised a lot at that front reception. And she was so good as Katie. So good. Also, lady, did you hear how she introduces herself? No, what did she say? I'm Kate. Oh, you know what? It's so funny.
绝对可以证实。在拍摄初稿中，字面意思上只写了凯蒂正在从一个大行李袋里拿出品牌各异的包包给安吉拉看。然后帕姆确实去了迈克尔的办公室。是的。而且有剧本台词的只有这个。凯蒂从一个大行李袋里拿出品牌各异的包包给安吉拉看，说，那个是手工刺绣的。安吉拉说上面有个污渍。然后就是帕姆和迈克尔进来的时候，德怀特跟在他们后面。
I thought I caught that when I was watching it. Yeah. And then when Michael walks up, she says, I'm Katie. And here's my fan theory. Ready? Okay. She doesn't want Michael to know her real name. She already has realized.
所以艾米·亚当斯在前台真的即兴发挥了很多。她演凯蒂演得太好了。太好了。还有，大姐，你听到她是怎样介绍自己的吗？没有，她说什么了？我是凯特。哦，你知道吗？太有趣了。
She sussed it out. When he's like Cox in the Hint House, she's like, I'm not telling him my real name. Well, we should back up a second because we skipped a scene, which is Dwight and Michael are in Michael's office. And they are brainstorming about what motivates people the most. Yeah. What's an incentive? Yes, because he's going to have to motivate the sales team to win this prize. At three minutes and 15 seconds, Dwight is hanging out over Michael's shoulder in that traditional spot.
我当在看的时候好像捕捉到了。是的。然后当迈克尔走过来时，她说，我是凯蒂。这是我的粉丝理论。准备好了吗？好的。她不想让迈克尔知道她的真名。她已经意识到了。
However, did you notice the credenza is missing? Yes. There's no credenza yet in Michael's office in season one. Not only that, there is a picture behind Dwight of Mount Rushmore. Yeah. Like with an American flag, that wasn't there. Yeah, I noticed going back again, I really saw how this was our real building. Yes. This wasn't our set yet.
她看穿了。当他像在暗示什么时，她心里想，我才不告诉他我的真名。好吧，我们应该退回一秒钟，因为我们跳过了一个场景，也就是德怀特和迈克尔在迈克尔的办公室里。他们在头脑风暴什么东西最能激励人们。是的。什么是激励？是的，因为他必须激励销售团队赢得这个奖品。在 3 分 15 秒时，德怀特像往常一样站在迈克尔的肩膀后面。
Well, I also want to note that Dwight is not wearing a mustard shirt in this episode. Oh, wow, I didn't catch that. That was kind of a good catch. That is a good catch. Well, like you said, Michael's going to get a glimpse of Katie through the blinds, and he's going to decide he does want to speak with her. Yeah. And he's going to go out, and he's going to tell her she can have the conference room. And then Pam says, but HR has a meeting in there. Oh, my gosh.
不过，你注意到边柜不见了吗？是的。第一季迈克尔的办公室里还没有边柜。不仅如此，德怀特身后还有一张拉什莫尔山的画。是的。就像带着一面美国国旗，以前没有。是的，我再次回看时注意到，我真的看到这就是我们真正的建筑。是的。这还不是我们的布景。
Michael says, you know what, give them the hallway with chairs. I mean, it's just ridiculous. Yeah, and in this moment, Michael's like, well, you know, decisiveness is one of the keys to being a successful businessman. Read that and small businessman. And then he has this really funny talking head where he says all the things that he reads, right? USA Today, American Way. He loves the in-flight magazine. And we talked about this in our original breakdown, but lady, if you can believe it, I have more to tell you about American Way magazine. I love in-flight magazines. I do too. And I'm sad a lot of airlines don't have them anymore.
嗯，我还想指出，德怀特在这集里没有穿芥末黄衬衫。哦，哇，我没注意到。这算是一个不错的发现。这确实是个好发现。嗯，就像你说的，迈克尔会透过百叶窗瞥一眼凯蒂，他会决定他确实想跟她说话。是的。然后他会出去，告诉她她可以使用会议室。然后帕姆说，但是人力资源部正在里面开会。哦，天哪。
That's what I was going to share. Oh. American Way magazine has been retired. Oh no. Yeah. According to an article in USA Today from June 2021, Dana Lawrence, American Airlines Managing Director of Global Brand Marketing said airlines are eliminating magazines due in large part to travelers changing tastes for in-flight
迈克尔说，你知道吗，给他们走廊，配上椅子。我的意思是，这太荒谬了。是的，在这个时刻，迈克尔就像是，好吧，你知道，果断是成为一个成功商人的关键之一。读作小商人。然后他有一个非常有趣的内心独白，讲述了他阅读的所有东西，对吧？今日美国，美国路。他喜欢机上杂志。我们在最初的剖析中讨论过这一点，但大姐，如果你敢相信的话，关于《美国路》杂志，我还有更多要告诉你的。我喜欢机上杂志。我也喜欢。我很遗憾很多航空公司现在都没有它们了。
entertainment since the introduction of Wi-Fi on planes. Oh. But then I got into the history of the American Way magazine. Is this going to make me more sad? I don't know. I found it fascinating. It started as a 22-page booklet called The American Way in 1966, and it was just an annual publication. And in the first issue, flight attendants were called stewardesses, and business travelers were pitched family fairs, offering half-priced tickets for your wife. It was like so madmen,
这就是我要分享的。哦。《美国路》杂志已经停刊了。哦，不。是的。根据《今日美国》2021 年 6 月的一篇文章，美国航空公司全球品牌营销常务董事达娜·劳伦斯表示，由于自飞机上引入 Wi-Fi 以来旅客对机上娱乐品味的改变，航空公司正在逐步取消杂志。哦。但后来我开始研究《美国路》杂志的历史。这会让我更难过吗？我不知道。我觉得很迷人。它于 1966 年作为一本名为《美国路》的 22 页小册子开始发行，当时它只是一份年度出版物。在第一期中，空姐被称为“空嫂”，而商务旅客则被推销家庭套票，为你的妻子提供半价机票。这太像《广告狂人》了，
this whole era. But then it moved to a monthly magazine, and American Way is very proud that they've had a few pop culture moments. They called them out in this article specifically the fact that Michael Scott played by Steve Correll bragged that he subscribed to it. They mentioned that he has that line where he says, there's some great articles in there. They did a great profile last month of Doris Roberts and where she likes to eat in Phoenix. I loved it.
整个这个时代。但后来它变成了月刊，《美国路》非常自豪他们有过一些流行文化时刻。他们在文章中特别指出了由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔饰演的迈克尔·斯科特吹嘘自己订阅了这本杂志。他们提到他有这样一句台词，他说，里面有一些很棒的文章。他们上个月对多丽丝·罗伯茨以及她喜欢在菲尼克斯哪里吃饭做了一篇很好的专题报道。我太喜欢了。
American Way said they did feature an article with Terry Bradshaw and where he likes to eat in Phoenix. So if you want to look that up, you can at least find that out. And then did you know that 12 years later, our very own Mindy Kaling was on the, cover of American Way magazine. She tweeted about it. She said, I'm proud to grace the cover of Michael Scott's favorite magazine American Way. That's so funny. Well, I have to go find that because I want to read it.
《美国路》杂志说他们确实刊登了一篇关于特里·布拉德肖以及他喜欢在菲尼克斯哪里吃饭的文章。所以如果你想查阅，你至少可以找到那个。然后你知道吗，12 年后，我们自己的明迪·卡林上了《美国路》杂志的封面。她在推特上谈到了这件事。她说，我很荣幸能登上迈克尔·斯科特最喜欢的杂志《美国路》的封面。太有趣了。好吧，我得去找找看，因为我想读一读。
Well, by 2021, Delta, Southwest, and United had also retired their in-flight magazines, but United decided to bring their hemispheres magazine back in digital form. Virgin Atlantic has also brought their magazine back online. You all know, we discussed the first time we broke this down, how I wrote an article about winning the poker tournament in Scotland for Hemisphere's Magazine. And I thought I would share an update. Okay. My family went back to Scotland in 2022. We returned to the same pub, the Wally Doug, this time with your kids. Yep. There was no poker tournament. We wanted there to be so bad. We were like, guys, listen, if we get there and there's a poker tournament, buckle in because mom's going to enter again. This has become like family
好吧，到 2021 年，达美航空、西南航空和联合航空也已经停刊了它们的机上杂志，但联合航空决定以数字形式带回他们的《半球》杂志。维珍大西洋航空也将他们的杂志重新搬上了网络。大家都知道，我们第一次剖析这个时讨论过，我是如何为《半球》杂志写了一篇关于在苏格兰赢得扑克锦标赛的文章的。我想分享一个最新进展。好的。我的家人在 2022 年回到了苏格兰。我们回到了同一家酒吧，Wally Doug，这次带上了你们的孩子。是的。没有扑克锦标赛。我们多么希望有啊。我们当时想，伙计们，听着，如果我们到了那里发现有扑克锦标赛，那就系好安全带，因为妈妈要再次参赛了。这已经成了家族传说。
lore. Remember when mom won the poker tournament in Scotland at midnight? Yeah. But there was no poker tournament, but when we got there, the bartender was like, oh my gosh, you're that girl who from the TV show that won the poker tournament here. And I was like, yes. And it had become like, she said, we get all these American tourists who come here now because you told that story. But it was sweet. We took a photo with our kids. And now on our shelf, we have the photo of me and Lee from our first trip and then a photo with the kids.
还记得妈妈半夜在苏格兰赢得扑克锦标赛的时候吗？是的。但没有扑克锦标赛，不过当我们到达那里时，酒保说，哦，天哪，你就是那个来自电视节目、在这里赢得扑克锦标赛的女孩。我当时想，是的。这已经变成了，她说，我们现在所有这些美国游客来这里都是因为你讲了那个故事。但这很甜蜜。我们和孩子们拍了张照片。现在在我们的书架上，有我和李第一次旅行的照片，然后是和孩子们的照片。
So cute. Well, now Michael is going to get Katie all set up in the conference room. And there is a moment in the scene. It makes me laugh every time I see this episode. What is it? You know, it's when Michael is telling. Katie, look, I'm just right next door. I mean, there used to be a window here. There's not anymore, but I'll be right there, you know? Yeah. So I was like, why does he mention that window?
太可爱了。好吧，现在迈克尔要把凯蒂在会议室里安顿好。这个场景里有一个瞬间。每次我看这一集都会让我笑出来。是什么？你知道的，就是迈克尔在对凯蒂说。凯蒂，听着，我就在隔壁。我的意思是，这里以前有一扇窗户。现在没有了，但我会在那里的，你知道吗？是的。所以我当时想，他为什么提到那扇窗户？
Is there more in the shooting draft about the fact that there was a window? This is how it reads in the shooting draft. Michael says to Katie, and this is my conference room. Make yourself at home. I'm right on the other side of the wall. Then there is this direction. Whistfully, Michael looks at the wall. There used to be a window there. He wraps on the wall. Anyway, that's where I'll be. So I'm like, what is the backstory about this? I emailed Mindy.
拍摄初稿中还有更多关于曾经有一扇窗户的内容吗？拍摄初稿中是这样写的。迈克尔对凯蒂说，这是我的会议室。别客气，就像在自己家一样。我就在墙的另一边。然后有这样的导演说明。迈克尔深情地看着墙。那里以前有一扇窗户。他敲了敲墙。不管怎样，我会在那里的。所以我当时想，关于这扇窗户背后的故事是什么？我给明迪发了电子邮件。
She did not email me back. No kidding. I was like, Mindy, I included the whole shooting draft description. I was like, please tell me there was a bigger story about this window. Poor Mindy. She's actually traveling. It's not her fault. We're going to see her for dinner soon.
她没有给我回邮件。不是吧。我当时想，明迪，我把整个拍摄初稿的描述都加进去了。我说，请告诉我关于这扇窗户有一个更大的故事。可怜的明迪。她其实正在旅行。这不怪她。我们很快就会和她一起吃晚饭。
We're going to see her for dinner. And she's going to be like, ang, I was on a plane. I couldn't want. Sorry. But I mean, he's wistfully looking at the wall. Oh, my gosh. I think here's my theory that there was a window there, but he would get distracted by the conference room. If there was anything happening, he would like peer in. And so they were like, nope, Jan was like no more window. So Jan took it out. I think Jan took it out. Who took it out is my question. I think did Toby take it out? Is this one of the reasons why Michael hates Toby? I think there. There were complaints about Michael in the window during the conference room meetings.
我们要一起吃晚饭。她会说，安吉，我在飞机上。我回不了。抱歉。但我的意思是，他深情地看着墙。哦，天哪。我觉得我的理论是，那里以前有一扇窗户，但他会被会议室分散注意力。如果有什么事情发生，他会偷看进去。所以他们就像，不，简就像是不要再有窗户了。所以简把它拆了。我觉得是简把它拆的。是谁拆的是我的问题。我觉得是托比拆的吗？这就是迈克尔恨托比的原因之一吗？我觉得在会议室开会期间，有人对迈克尔和那扇窗户有抱怨。
And I think corporate took it out. Well, this scene of him watching Katie, like, unpack her purses and he's just lingering. Oh, man. It's a little expanded from the original. There's just a lot more of him awkwardly watching her and asking if there's anything he can do to help, you know, until she's finally like, a cup of coffee would be great. And then he's like, I knew it. I knew it. The bucks.
我觉得公司把它拆了。好吧，这个他看着凯蒂收拾包包而他却在一旁流连的场景。天哪。比原版稍微扩展了一点。有更多他尴尬地看着她并问是否有他能帮忙的画面，你知道的，直到她终于说，一杯咖啡就太好了。然后他说，我就知道。我就知道。钱。
You're another addict. She's like, what are you talking about? He's so excited to get her this cup of coffee. And then there's a new talking head from Michael where he says, it's probably not charming to say so, but people find him charming. There's a whole runner of Michael in this episode talking about just what a catch he is, how charming he is. It's all of these extra talking heads. We're going to point them out. And then there's this great scene between Kevin and Pam.
你又是个瘾君子。她说，你在说什么？他为能给她端来这杯咖啡感到非常兴奋。然后迈克尔有了一个新的内心独白，他说，说出来可能不太迷人，但人们觉得他很迷人。这一集里有整条关于迈克尔的支线，都在谈论他是一个多么好的伴侣，他有多么迷人。全都是这些额外的内心独白。我们会指出来的。然后凯文和帕姆之间有一个很棒的场景。
We talked about this when we originally watched where Kevin is just basically, saying the purse girl is prettier than Pam. And Pam's like, that's rude. Yes, we talked about how I kept breaking when we were shooting this. I can see you breaking. Now we are coming to something I am so excited about. You know, Jenna, how many times if we watch the show now, but when you come across something new, it is still so fun. Yeah. There is the scene. I have so many questions about the scene. Okay. Remember how Pam said there was an A.R. meeting in the conference room and Michael says move them to the hallway and give them chairs. Well, here it is.
我们在最初观看时讨论过这个，凯文基本上是在说，包包女孩比帕姆更漂亮。帕姆说，这太粗鲁了。是的，我们讨论过我当时拍摄时是如何一直笑场的。我能看到你在笑场。现在我们来到了一个让我非常兴奋的环节。你知道吗，珍娜，如果我们现在看这部剧多少次，但当你遇到一些新鲜事物时，它依然那么有趣。是的。有这样一个场景。我对这个场景有太多的疑问。好的。还记得帕姆说会议室里有人力资源部会议，而迈克尔说让他们搬到走廊去并给他们椅子吗？好吧，它在这里。
This is an added scene. I think this hallway is three feet wide. It is so narrow. It just fits the chairs, basically. And it's Kelly, Creed, Meredith, Toby, Devin and Luanne. They are smushed into this tiny space. They have cups of coffee, a plate of pastries, lots of papers, a big whiteboard that keeps falling and they're trying to hold it.
这是一个新增的场景。我觉得这个走廊只有三英尺宽。太窄了。基本上只能放得下椅子。里面有凯利、克里德、梅雷迪思、托比、德文和露安。他们被挤在这个狭小的空间里。他们拿着咖啡杯、一盘糕点、许多文件、一个一直在掉、他们正试图扶住的大白板。
It's so funny. And I went to the shooting draft to see what it said about this scene. and it's not in there. It's not in the shooting draft. And it's not in the candy bag alts. So I don't know if there were some last minute pages that flew in, but it's not in the shooting draft. Well, what's interesting is that this is the first and only time we see this full hallway on the show. It was the hallway that goes behind the back window of the conference room.
太有趣了。我去翻了拍摄初稿，看看里面是怎么写这个场景的，结果里面没有。它不在拍摄初稿里。也不在糖果袋的备选镜头里。所以我不知道是不是有一些最后一分钟飞页加进来的，但它确实不在拍摄初稿里。好吧，有趣的是，这是我们在剧里第一次也是唯一一次看到这条完整的走廊。这就是会议室后窗后面的那条走廊。
To get to it, you would go through that door next to the storage shelf. and like go to the left. Right. Okay. So the storage supply shelf where Kevin was standing. Yep. There's the door to the left. You go through that door.
要到达那里，你得穿过储物架旁边的那扇门，然后向左走。没错。好的。所以凯文站着那个储物用品架。没错。左边有扇门。你穿过那扇门。
And then that's where that hallway was. And this was a real thing in this real building. But it was really weird because it was like there was a window at the end of the conference room, but it just went to this hallway. And then on the other wall of the hallway were a couple of windows that actually went outside. Okay. I don't know what this.
然后那就是那条走廊所在的地方。这在现实中的这座建筑里是真实存在的。但真的很奇怪，因为就像会议室尽头有一扇窗户，但它只是通向这条走廊。然后走廊的另一面墙上还有几扇实际上通往室外的窗户。好的。我不知道这条。
hallway was four. It made no sense. It made no sense. It's like where the hallway, it's where Dwight, you know, lit the fire. Yes, that's right. But that was after we had recreated it on our set. We recreated part of this hallway. But in that episode, which is stress relief when Dwight starts the fire in the trash can, you only see the right corner. You never see this view behind the conference room again. So, when we were watching the final episodes of the show and I became very curious about where does this door go? And I wrote Dave Rogers and I said, where does that door go by the storage shelf? Yeah, what's the story? What happens if you turn left? We know what happens. Right.
走廊是干什么用的。这根本说不通。这就像德怀特放火的那个走廊。是的，没错。但那是在我们在布景里重建它之后。我们重建了这条走廊的一部分。但在那一集里，也就是德怀特在垃圾桶里纵火的《减压》，你只能看到右拐角。你再也看不到会议室后面的这个视角了。所以，当我们观看该剧的最后一集并开始对这扇门通向哪里感到好奇时？我给戴夫·罗杰斯写信说，储物架旁边的那扇门通向哪里？是的，有什么故事？如果你向左转会发生什么？我们知道会发生什么。对。
You get to our hair and makeup stations and you get to where we would eat lunch. But I'm like, where in the world of this building of this show did we think that went? And Dave Rogers, we joke about it, he sent me back a dissertation on all the hallways of Dunder Mifflin. Yes, yes. Are you about to share Dave Rogers' dissertation on hallways? I am. Oh, my God, I'm getting comfortable.
你来到了我们的发型和化妆区，来到了我们吃午饭的地方。但我在想，在剧集的这座建筑世界里，我们认为那里通向哪里？我们开玩笑说，戴夫·罗杰斯给我回了一篇关于邓德米夫林所有走廊的论文。是的，是的。你准备好分享戴夫·罗杰斯关于走廊的论文了吗？是的。哦，天哪，我坐舒服了。
I can't wait. So, Dave shared with me that there are a lot of Dunder Mifflin floor plans that were made by fans that try to explain where all of the doors and hallways go. Okay. In our world. Most of those show this hallway as leading to a set of stairs. So you know that door that it's at the end past the break room? You know how?
我等不及了。所以，戴夫跟我分享说，有很多由粉丝制作的邓德米夫林平面图，试图解释所有的门和走廊通向哪里。好的。在我们的大世界里。其中大部分都显示这条走廊通向一组楼梯。所以你知道那扇在休息室过去的尽头的门吗？你知道吗？
Yes, yes, right? Most of the fan theories, they have drawn a set of stairs that you can get to from either that door by the break room or a door at the end of the little hallway, okay? But there was no door at the end of this hallway. And this superfan scene must blow that out the window. Yes. Because you see it. Yes. Is that a phrase blow it out the window? Then I just make that up. Did I do one of my things? I don't think it is a phrase. It's definitely not a phrase. What is it? Does it blow it wide open? I don't know. I'm saying it blows this theory away. Angela, are you thinking? blow it out of the water? Does it blow it out of the water? Maybe. It also blows it out the window.
是的，是的，对吧？大多数粉丝理论都在休息室旁边的门或小走廊尽头的门画了一组楼梯，你可以从那里到达，好的？但这条走廊的尽头没有门。这个超级粉丝场景一定会把它彻底推翻。是的。因为你看到了。是的。那是个短语叫把它彻底推翻吗？还是我刚编的？我是不是说了什么我的口头禅？我觉得这不是个短语。这绝对不是个短语。那是什么？是不是把它彻底粉碎？我不知道。我说的是它把这个理论给粉碎了。安吉拉，你在想什么？把它抛诸脑后？是不是把它抛诸脑后？也许吧。它也把它扔出窗外了。
I'm trying to imagine like when you would do that. You'd be like, you know what? I'm going to take that and I'm going to blow it out the window. Oh, well, I don't know. It does. If you need to clear a room of smoke, you might open a window and blow it out of the window. I don't know. Anyway, I'm sorry. Go ahead. Well, I was going to say, in reality, both of those doors led to a big storage closet, which is where I believe props would keep our props. But in the world of Dunder Mifflin, we created our own Dunder Mifflin floor plan because we had to have a sense of where did these things go in the fictional world. And even on the Dunder Mifflin floor plan, we had to have a sense of, floor plan, this hallway goes nowhere.
我试图想象什么时候你会这么做。你会想，你知道吗？我要把那个拿起来，然后把它扔出窗外。哦，好吧，我不知道。确实如此。如果你需要清除房间里的烟雾，你可能会打开窗户把它扔出窗外。我不知道。不管怎样，对不起。请继续。嗯，我要说的是，在现实中，这两扇门都通向一个大储藏室，我相信道具组会把我们的道具放在那里。但在邓德米夫林的世界里，我们创建了自己的邓德米夫林平面图，因为我们必须对这些东西在虚构的世界里去了哪里有一个概念。甚至在邓德米夫林平面图上，我们必须对平面图有个概念，这条走廊是通往哪里的呢，哪里也不通。
Oh, no. It goes to nothing. On our official floor plan, we do show that the door by the break room does lead to a fictional staircase. And I think that is the staircase that would go to the spot where we saw Pam crying on the bench when Dwight comforts her. Which was the side of the warehouse. Yeah.
哦，不。它通往虚无。在我们的官方平面图上，我们确实显示休息室旁边的门确实通向一个虚构的楼梯。我认为那是通往我们看到帕姆在长椅上哭泣时德怀特安慰她的那个地方的楼梯。那是仓库的一侧。是的。
So that door by the break room, I believe, would take you down to the bench. that part of the building. And then also in our like Dunder Mifflin lobby elevator area, there is a staircase that would lead you down to caffeine corner. Okay. Okay. But my one question when looking at all these floor plans was, where is that long hallway that Michael is always running down that connects between those two stairwells? Oh, the writer's hallway? Yeah, we know it was the writer's hallway, but like where? Because there's windows.
所以休息室旁边的那扇门，我相信会带你走到长椅。建筑的那部分。然后还在我们的邓德米夫林大堂电梯区，有一个楼梯可以带你走到咖啡角。好的。好的。但我看所有这些平面图时唯一的疑问是，迈克尔总是跑着穿过的那条连接这两个楼梯间的长走廊在哪里？哦，编剧走廊？是的，我们知道那是编剧走廊，但到底在哪里？因为有窗户。
Yeah. So where is that? I don't know. And why wouldn't HR go there? It's so much room here. I don't know. I mean, why didn't they go to the break room? Why didn't they go to so many places?
是的。那在哪里？我不知道。为什么人力资源部不去那里？这里有这么大的空间。我不知道。我的意思是，他们为什么不去休息室？他们为什么不去那么多地方？
That's true. The kitchen. Yes. Also, looking at this floor plan, there is another door that we, we never reveal where it goes or what it is. It leads to nowhere. And that is the door in the annex by Kelly's desk. Yes. The door by accounting, we eventually reveal is a storage locker where the dock crew keeps their stuff. And where Jim and Pam hooked up once. Yeah. But we never see behind the door in the annex. The door by Kelly's desk in the annex.
确实。厨房。是的。还有，看着这个平面图，还有另一扇门，我们从未透露它通向哪里或它是什么。它通向虚无。那就是附楼里凯利办公桌旁的门。是的。我们最终透露会计部旁的门是一个储物柜，码头工作人员把他们的东西放在那里。也是吉姆和帕姆曾经勾搭过的地方。是的。但我们从未见过附楼里的那扇门后面是什么。附楼里凯利办公桌旁的门。
As you would walk in and out of it, it went to our bathrooms. It was a back way to the bathrooms in the real world. And there was a red paintbrush, remember? It was like a little piece of art that sat on top of the shelf. It was like a, it looked like a paintbrush, but it was painting a streak of red, but it was like a little sculpture. Oh, yeah. Do you remember it? Oh, yeah.
当你进出它时，它通向我们的洗手间。那是现实世界中通往洗手间的后路。那里有一把红色的画笔，还记得吗？就像一件小艺术品，放在架子顶上。它看起来像一把画笔，但它正在画一道红色的笔触，但它就像一个雕塑。哦，是的。你还记得吗？哦，是的。
Yeah. That was the weirdest thing. I know. I don't know why. I just remembered that. I don't know. Well, anyway, there it is, everybody. That was the hallways.
是的。那是最奇怪的事情。我懂的。我不知道为什么。我只是记住了那个。我不知道。好吧，无论如何，大家都在这儿了。这就是走廊。
The dissertation on hallways and doorways. I was talking to Paul Lieberstein recently, and he pointed out that none of the windows of our interior set match the windows of our exterior building. And it said it's always driven him crazy. And fans never talk about it. Yes, that's right. We got in a whole conversation with him about this. It's actually a pet peeve of his. when you look at the Dundra Mifflin building from the parking lot, that the windows don't match
关于走廊和门廊的论文。我最近跟保罗·利伯斯坦谈过，他指出我们内部布景的窗户没有一个与我们外部建筑的窗户相匹配。他说这总是让他抓狂。而粉丝们从不谈论它。是的，没错。我们跟他进行了关于这整件事的对话。这实际上是他的一个宠物恨。当你从停车场看邓德米夫林大楼时，窗户根本不匹配
when you're inside looking out. He said there's all these floor plans and people worry about the hallways and the doors, but no one talks about the windows. Blow it out the window, Paul. Blow it out the window. Now we have the scene between Kevin and Dwight. You know, in the original, they're just sort of like sipping. It looks like water.
当你从里面往外看时。他说这里有所有的平面图，人们担心走廊和门，但没有人谈论窗户。把它扔出窗外吧，保罗。把它扔出窗外。现在我们来到了凯文和德怀特之间的场景。你知道，在原版中，他们只是在抿着。看起来像水。
Maybe they're by the water cooler in the bullpen and they're watching Katie. and they don't have dialogue. But in the superfan episode, the full scene is there. And they're looking at her and they're trying to figure out, is she local, is she from Scranton or is she foreign? You know, would they have known her? And they're sort of, you know, they're ogling her. Is that the right word? Yes, I believe so. Okay. Well, I want you to know something. In the shooting draft, this scene was actually between Jim and Dwight. Not Dwight and Kevin. Really? Yeah. You sort of see that Jim is behind them and he doesn't say much. Well, in the shooting draft, it actually starts with Jim and Dwight, and I want to read it to you. Dwight stares at Katie and flosses. He examines the bits of
也许他们在公用办公区的饮水机旁，他们在看着凯蒂。而且他们没有台词。但在超级粉丝集中，完整的场景就在那里。他们看着她，试图弄清楚，她是本地人，她是来自斯克兰顿还是外国人？你知道，他们会认识她吗？他们有点，你知道，他们在对她抛媚眼。是这个词吗？是的，我相信是的。好的。好吧，我想让你知道一件事。在拍摄初稿中，这个场景实际上是吉姆和德怀特之间的。而不是德怀特和凯文。真的吗？是的。你有点看到吉姆在他们身后，他没说太多。好吧，在拍摄初稿中，它实际上是从吉姆和德怀特开始的，我想读给你听。德怀特盯着凯蒂并用牙线剔牙。他检查着牙线上的食物残渣
food on his floss closely. Jim says, that's more of a bathroom activity, isn't it? Dwight says, not enough natural light in the bathroom. And then it goes into the scene of them watching Katie. But Dwight is flossing his teeth in the bullpen. Isn't that so gross? You know, I'm glad that was cut from both the original and the superfan. I don't think I ever need to see that. It's so gross. Well, now Dwight is going to have a talking head. This was also in the original episode where he just talks about how the purse girl like hits everything on his list. Yep. We talked about this scene because it has the very famous line that Shrews produce very thirsty babies. Dwight doesn't need the boobs for him, though. They're for his babies. For his babies. Yeah. That's why he likes her boobs. That's right.
I thought the angle of this talking head was very interesting. He's inside the conference room, but he doesn't have Stanley's desk behind him. Nope. It's actually like he's sitting almost right by the door to the conference room, which is closed. And over his shoulder, you can see Jim. You can see Creed at the copier. Leanne crosses behind him. I mean, so much activity. So much activity, but this is the early days. We did lots of crosses and back and forths. We now have a new scene. Dwight is going to go into the conference room and try his best to flirt with Katie. He's going to look at her purses. In the script, the scene was set up like this. Dwight walks over to Katie without his glasses on. He holds up a purse very close to his eyes. He looks at the person says it's really well made. Good stitching. Excellent fabric. It was not scripted for Rain to then bat the purse back and forth around as Dwight. He improvised that.
And I want you to go to eight minutes and 23 seconds because you can see Rain starting to break at himself. He's laughing at his own bit. I love that. Well, behind Katie's shoulder, we have the Dunder Mifflin calendar blitz. Yeah. It's this whiteboard and it looks like a sales chart. Maybe this is where we're figuring out who's going to win this incentive at the end of the day. And the names on it were very curious to me.
Oh. They were Jim, Dwight, Stanley, Phyllis, Andy. Andy? Yes. Andy. Roger. Who's Roger? And Michelle with one L.
Who the hell are Roger and Michelle? I don't know. Oh, my God. I'm not sure. These super fan episodes are messing with my head. Well, the scene continues here now. Dwight is asking Katie about a specific purse. He's like, you sell a lot of these.
She says, yes, it's very popular. He then says, is it waterproof? And she responds, I'm not sure. It's faux snake skin. And then Dwight says, snakes are waterproof, so I'm betting that it is waterproof. But it's faux snakes. I know. Also, snake skin, it's not waterproof.
It's not? No. Did you look it up? I did look it up. I love that. Snakes are not waterproof, but their skin permeability can change to help them retain water. That's according to the internet, people. Well, he also has a line where he asks her if she knows the difference between a snake and an eel.
And if not, he can look it up. I looked up the difference between a snake and an eel. Well, an eel is ocean, right? It's saltwater animal. Well, Angela, according to Americanoceans.org, there are several differences between snakes and eels. Should we start with their habitat? Yes, I can tell you I swam up right on a Moray eel one time, face to face. How was that?
A little scary. Yeah. Well, eels can live in both freshwater or saltwater. In fact, the European eel migrates from freshwater to saltwater to breed. However, snakes are found mostly on land. But in a variety of habitats like deserts, forests, and swamps. Both snakes and eels lack pectoral fins and have scales, but eels have a slimy skin, whereas snakes have dry scaly skin. Eels have gills, snakes have lungs.
Eels have a tail fin that runs the length of their body, but snakes have no tail. Also, diet, most eels are coniferous, and they eat fish and crustaceans and worms. snakes are also carnivorous and eat things like rodents, birds, and other reptiles. I mean, I've got more. Do you want to hear about their reproductive cycles? I don't know. Well, buckle in because I'm going to tell you. I don't know if I want to know how they do it.
Eels lay their eggs in the ocean and the larvae drift back to freshwater environments. Snakes lay eggs or give birth to live young. So different. I knew that snakes laid eggs. Well, I think it's very different. Yeah. Snakes and eels are not closely related is the bottom line. Snakes are reptiles, eels are fish.
They belong to totally different classes of animals. So what's the moral here? You can look like something else but not have anything in common with it. Yeah, that's the moral. That's the moral of that tipta. That's why I did it. Because I wanted to make that. I wanted everyone to know that you go on something.
What is going on? I think what's going on. We've been here for six hours. Oh, you guys, we tried to do a double recording today, and this is what happens. Oh, no. Oh, gosh, I have mascara all over me. This is what you get. This is what you get.
Double record day. Loop de doo. Well, that's the moral of the story. I don't know what you do with them. That you look like the same thing as something, but you're really different. That's, everyone, take that into your weekend. Oh, my gosh. If you meet a set of twins, they might look very similar.
But they're not. They're different people. And the next time you encounter a set of twins, you're going to remember this podcast and the moral of the story. And you're going to say one's an eel and one's a snake. Exactly. Exactly. They look the same, but they're different. But also, I want to say something.
But also, snakes and eels don't even look that much alike. They're both like. I don't know long. They're both long and I guess they don't have feet. They know, yeah. All right. We should move on. We should.
Katie says, Oh, no. Guys, can we even finish this episode? This is off the rails. Oh, I was going to say it. This is out the window. This is totally gone out the window. What?
I don't know. It said, this is something that was not funny until we talked about your deep dive. Anyway, Katie says, you're really into reptiles, huh? And Dwight says, my belt is made of alligator. Then he pulls his shirt up. He's going to show off this belt. And that's when Michael comes in. And I would like to point something out.
Michael is going to have a runner in this episode. I didn't share this before of some seriously snarky behavior. Oh, Michael Snark. Michael Snark. His snarky behavior is going to be pointing out what he thinks are people's shortcomings so that they seem inferior and so that Katie will like him. So when he walks in, he says to Dwight, wear your glasses. And then he says to Katie, he wears glasses. Snark. Yeah. There's going to be more. Now Michael is going to offer to give Katie a tour of the office and he tells Ryan to watch her purses. Yeah. She doesn't want to go though. She's like my purses. He's like, they're fine. Yeah. Then we have a new Dwight talking. head. It's a classic. This is some classic Dwight here where he describes his ideal woman. Oh, yeah. You know, his ideal woman would be Koniko Taka, whose parents were assassinated and she was taken in by a wealthy, cruel businessman. But then she practiced a keto for years. Yes, to one day
secretly avenge her parents' deaths. This is who Dwight wants. Yes. Now Michael is giving Katie the tour, they're walking through the kitchen. I have a few background catches I missed the first time around. Same, same. Is yours the dry erase board that says please clean up? And it also says groceries. 10 minutes, 10 seconds. Yes, it is on the wall and it is right by the door that leads to the bullpen. At 10 minutes and 13 seconds, why is Oscar taking a phone call by the bathroom door? He is seated in a chair next to the door to the men's bathroom. There are so many other places to take a phone call. Why would you sit there? Well, I guess so that Michael can walk by and make fun of his name. I guess so. He's also sitting under a sign that says, now hiring friendly people with
smiles. Also, there's another sign by Oscar. It's another all-hands meeting. You know that all-hands meeting that's been up by Pam's desk this whole first season, it's on Saturday. No date. Just Saturday. It's a lot of meetings. Pam has a lot of a talking head where she says she likes having Katie around because it's another person for Michael to interact with. Now we've got a couple of new moments. We see Kelly trying to pick out a purse and Ryan is sort of now, I guess, in the role of salesperson. I went to the shooting draft because I was like, what is happening? Yeah. It said this. There is a shot of Ryan efficiently selling Kelly a purse. Oh, I have two things to say. Is this our very first sign that Ryan is a con man?
Oh. He's so shady. He's selling purses that aren't his. I bet if she gave him money he might pocket it. I think you're right. And then also this is our first moment of Kelly and Ryan. And it's so weird because I wonder if this happens to people when they're rewatching the show. I know what's going to happen with Kelly and Ryan. And by the way, Kelly right now is still old Kelly. She's not full Mindy yet. And so I'm like, okay, the purse she picked up is leading towards. full Mindy. Yeah. But she's still kind of dressed like old Kelly. Yeah. And I don't think there's any flirtation here. In fact, at the end of this episode, Dwight is going to give Kelly a purse, almost like hinting that there could be romance there. Yeah.
All the romances are off. And I'm a little confused because I know too much. It's so early. But when you look at this moment, one of Kelly's very first interactions with Ryan in the documentary, is him being dishonest with her. Yes. When we get to our episode on All About Ryan Howard, I think we're going to have, we'll really track his, what would you call that? Deception.
Yes. All right. Now we have another new scene, Angela, that you pointed out in our All About Michael Scott episode. Michael is continuing to give Katie a tour of the office. Yeah. He says, thank you, Al Gore for the internet. And he can't believe that you couldn't send messages electronically 10 years ago. And Katie's like, you could.
And he's like, fine, 20 years ago. Still pretty cool. Now Michael is going to introduce Katie to Toby. And they kind of hit it off. Yeah. Toby notices that she has a Bishop O'Hara ring. And he's like, oh, my God, did you go there? And she's like, yeah.
And he's like, I went there. And they're starting to bond. And of course, Michael has to cut it off. Yeah. this is another Michael Snarky moment. I want to point out something. In our initial breakdown of this, I share that there's a lot more in deleted scenes of Michael being snarky
about Toby's divorce. And lady, they didn't even include them all in the superfan episode. Really? Uh-huh. There's actually more in deleted scenes on the DVD. We never played it, and I think we should hear it. Yeah. Yeah, me too.
Cool. What, you were you there? 89. Toby's divorced. God, that's hard. That really ripped you up. She got the kids, right? That'll damage you. Sorry, man. That's a... Right a bad one. How much you're paying her? You can't even afford anything now, right?
Cool. What, you were you there? 89. Toby's divorced. God, that's hard. That really ripped you up. She got the kids, right? That's'll damage you. Sorry, man. That's a... Right a bad one. How much you're paying her? You can't even afford anything now, right?
You're all right though, right? Don't ask me for a raise! Oh, cup of soup's a good idea though. That'll... That's a good budgetary thing to do. Well, they're good snacks. are good food, good meals, good lunch. Ramen noodles are good, too. You're still sleeping in the car? No.
Because he slept in the car a couple times. Still. Are you still taking the antidepressants? This is a good idea. That'll help. It'll help, man. I'm going to go back to my table. Okay.
I'll see you in a bit. See in a bit. Michael. Michael Snark. Yeah. Yeah. And we do notice on Toby's desk there is a cup of soup. There's also a piggy bank that just says bread, cash money.
Okay. And there is a picture of a red Jeep on the wall next to him. Is this Toby's dream car? I don't know. That's a good question. Did she get the Jeep and the divorce? Sounds like she got everything. Mm-hmm.
Well, now we are going to go into the kitchen. Roy, Jim, and Pam are eating lunch. And Roy just keeps going on and on about how attractive Katie is. And we talked a lot about this in our last breakdown. You know, Pam is seated in between Roy and Jim. And Roy is like, I don't understand why you don't go for her helper, you know? If we weren't dating, I'd be all over that. And Pam's like, we're not dating.
We're engaged. She storms out of the kitchen. Here's something we did not talk about in our last breakdown. I have something as well. Is it at 12 minutes and 52 seconds? No. At the end of the scene. No.
I'll let you go first then. Mine's at the very end of the scene. It's a button at the end of the scene. Well, first of all, at the very top, Roy, and I did not catch this the first time, calls Jim Jimmy. He says, hey, Jimmy, what do you think of that little purse girl, huh? And I'm like, oh my gosh, this made me think of another fan theory, which is, Jimmy is what you call someone when you grow up with them. Did Roy and Jim know each other?
Like in elementary school? Did they grow up together? Was Jim called Jimmy when he was little? Oh, wow. I don't know. And that makes it even more layered that Roy got Pam. But that would mean that Pam knew Jim growing up? I don't know.
Where is Jim from originally? How long has Pam known Roy? Does Jim's family live in town? Do his brothers and parents live? live in town? Do we know? Their house was in town with the clown. Oh yeah, that's right. So they did. But how long has Pam known Roy? I mean, in my backstory, Pam and Roy at least went to high school together. Well, Roy and Jimmy might have gone to elementary school together. That's crazy. It's my fan theory. Okay, what was your thing?
Well, I'm just as excited about this, but at 12 minutes, and 52 seconds. Jim John is eating carrots. Oh, yes. I saw that. I think this is the first Jim John carrot eating. It starts so early. So early.
好吧，我对此也一样兴奋，但在12分52秒时，吉姆·约翰正在吃胡萝卜。噢，对的。我看到了。我想这是吉姆·约翰第一次吃胡萝卜。开始得真早。太早了。
He has a sandwich and carrots. Pam had a salad and a juice box. Hmm. Adorable. And Roy has pizza. Jim has a talking head now where he just talks about like, hey, you know, Pam and I are good buddies. She comes to me with her problems like work or Roy, and those are pretty much her two problems. Well, now Dwight and Jim are watching Katie from their desks.
他吃了一个三明治和胡萝卜。帕姆吃了一份沙拉和一个果汁盒。嗯。真可爱。而罗伊吃的是披萨。吉姆现在有一个独白镜头，他在里面谈论着，嘿，你知道的，我和帕姆是好哥们儿。她带着工作或罗伊之类的问题来找我，而这基本上就是她的两个问题。好吧，现在德怀特和吉姆正坐在各自的办公桌前看着凯蒂。
And Jim is really going to mess with Dwight. You know, he's saying she'd be perfect for you. And Dwight says, well, she's been talking to Michael a lot. And then I really loved this little couplet of dialogue. Jim says, so what? You're assistant regional manager. And Dwight says, assistant to the regional manager. And then Jim has this great line where he says, well, you know what, Dwight, he's your work boss, okay?
而吉姆真的要去捉弄德怀特了。你知道的，他说她对你来说太完美了。德怀特说，嗯，她跟迈克尔聊了很多。然后我真的很喜欢这段简短的对话。吉姆说，那又怎样？你是助理区域经理。德怀特说，是区域经理助理。接着吉姆说了一句很棒的台词，他说，噢，你知道吗，德怀特，他是你的工作老板，好吗？
He is not your relationship boss. That's right. It's powerful. I saw two things in this scene that are great examples of stuff we've talked about on the podcast before. Let's hear him. At 13 minutes and 27 seconds, Dwight's chair does not have arms. This was the question. crap chair. Oh, the s one pass around. Yes. It's in this scene. I didn't think it ever played prominently
他不是你的恋爱老板。没错。这很有力量。我在这一幕中看到了两件事，它们是我们以前在播客中讨论过的内容的好例子。让我们听听。在13分27秒时，德怀特的椅子没有扶手。这就是那个问题。垃圾椅子。哦，那个传开的椅子。是的。就是在这场戏里。我原以为它不会在
in a scene, but somehow before Rain started this scene, he got the crap chair and there are no arms on this chair. Oh my gosh. And it made me laugh. It brought me back because I was like, I remember when I get stuck with that chair without the arms. I remember purposely going to set before Brian and Oscar. so I wouldn't get crap chair. We just move it around to all our desks and you'd be like, oh, it really motivated you to get to set early. Also, at 13 minutes and 35 seconds, there is so clearly a faky document on Dwight's monitor and Jim's monitor. I saw that. It's also on merit of this monitor.
一场戏里表现得那么突出，但不知怎的，在雷恩开始拍这场戏之前，他拿到了那把垃圾椅子，这把椅子上没有扶手。噢天哪。这让我大笑。它勾起了我的回忆，因为我想起了我被那把没有扶手的椅子难住的时候。我记得我曾故意在布莱恩和奥斯卡之前赶到片场，这样我就不会拿到垃圾椅子了。我们只是把它搬到我们所有的办公桌旁，你会觉得，哦，这真的激励你早点到片场。另外，在13分35秒时，德怀特的显示器和吉姆的显示器上非常明显地有一个假的文档。我看到了。它也在这个显示器的优点上。
The same one? No, they're all slightly different, but I mean, they really look almost like a sticker. you can just tell that these computers don't really work. If you like just notice that in every single scene, it's the same faky document on these monitors. But I think especially telling is the fact that Kate is not playing solitaire in the background. Right. The scene with Jim and Dwight is going to continue. And Jim basically says, you know what, if there's a lull in conversation between you and Katie, just buy a purse.
同一个吗？不，它们都略有不同，但我的意思是，它们看起来真的很像贴纸。你一眼就能看出这些电脑其实不能用。如果你仔细注意就会发现，在每一场戏里，这些显示器上都是同一个假文档。但我认为特别说明问题的是，凯特没有在后台玩纸牌游戏。没错。吉姆和德怀特的戏还要继续。吉姆基本上是说，你知道吗，如果你们和凯蒂的对话陷入冷场，就买个钱包。
And Dwight's like, what? I don't want a purse. Purses are for girls. And Jim says Dwight, that is not necessarily true. Do you read GQ? Because I do. And they're like many briefcases, all right? Lots of guys have them.
而德怀特却说，什么？我才不要钱包。钱包是给女生用的。吉姆说，德怀特，那可不一定。你看《GQ》吗？因为我看。它们就像迷你公文包，好吧？很多男人都有。
Well, this made me curious. What does GQ say? What is the buzz about the MERS, the man purse? Well, Ange, should we take a break? And when we come back, you'll tell us. Oh, get ready. Okay. Because when we come back, I have a lot to say about men's purses.
好吧，这引起了我的好奇。GQ是怎么说的？关于MERS，也就是男士手包，现在有什么热门话题？好吧，安吉，我们要休息一下吗？等我们回来，你来告诉我们。哦，准备好吧。好的。因为等我们回来，我对男士手包有很多话要说。
I have a lot of hearing about them that I want to do. So we're a good match. That sounds like a catchy phrase. I have a lot of hearing I want to do about that. We're inventing a lot of phrases that are going to catch on this week. They're all gold. All gold. We are back and Jim is really trying to pump Dwight up.
我有很多想听的关于它们的事情。所以我们俩很般配。这听起来像是一个catchy的短语。我有很多关于那个想听的话题。我们这周发明了许多将会流行起来的短语。它们全都是金句。全是金句。我们回来了，吉姆真的在努力给德怀特打气。
to get him, to have the confidence, to go in and talk to Katie. And he says, listen, if there's a lull in the conversation, just buy a purse. Yeah. And Dwight says, I don't want a purse. Purses are for girls. And Jim says, Dwight, that is not necessarily true. Do you read GQ? I do.
为了让他鼓起信心，走过去和凯蒂说话。他说，听着，如果对话陷入冷场，就买个钱包。是的。德怀特说，我不要钱包。钱包是给女生用的。吉姆说，德怀特，那可不一定。你看《GQ》吗？我看。
And they're like many briefcases. Lots of guys have them. Well, lady, I was curious. What does GQ say about men's purses? What do they say? I looked it up. GQ certainly has a lot of great links to great bags, and I found several articles, and I'm going to share with you the evolution of the men's purse. Well, like I said before the break, I am ready to receive this information into my ears.
它们就像迷你公文包。很多男人都有。好吧，美女，我很好奇。GQ对男士手包是怎么说的？他们是怎么说的？我查了一下。GQ确实有很多关于好包的精彩链接，我找到了好几篇文章，我要跟你们分享男士手包的演变史。好吧，就像我在中场休息前说的那样，我已经准备好把这些信息接收到我的耳朵里了。
There it is. Just eloquently said. So per a New York Post article written by Brooke Cato, I'll put the full article in our stories, Brooke says this, long before there were handbags or even pockets, there were girdle pouches for men. You would wear your girdle pouch. It would hold spices and money. How about that? Huh. Huh.
就是这样。简直是巧舌如簧。那么根据布鲁克·卡托（Brooke Cato）为《纽约邮报》撰写的一篇文章，我会把整篇文章发到我们的动态里，布鲁克是这样说的：早在有手袋甚至口袋之前，男士们就有束腹袋。你会佩戴你的束腹袋。它用来装香料和钱。觉得怎么样？哈。哈。
So men had a type of satchel that they would strap to themselves. Okay. Then per GQ magazine, later came a structural rectangular briefcase meant for carrying papers to and from work. This was during the Industrial Revolution. Then there were these certain big moments sort of. in the zeitgeis where bags were featured. For example, the satchel really expanded because of Harrison Ford's character, Indiana Jones. He has that cross-body satchel in the 80s movie. So did a bunch of men start carrying satchels to be like Harrison Ford in that movie? Yes. Wow. And then there were these moments in the
所以男士们有一种斜挎包，他们会把它绑在自己身上。好的。然后根据《GQ》杂志的报道，后来出现了结构化的长方形公文包，用来携带公文上下班。这发生在工业革命时期。然后时代精神中出现了一些特定的重要时刻，包包在其中大放异彩。例如，由于哈里森·福特饰演的角色印第安纳·琼斯，斜挎包真正流行开来。他在80年代的电影中背着那种跨肩斜挎包。那么有很多男人开始背斜挎包来想像那部电影里的哈里森·福特吗？是的。哇。然后还有这些时刻
90s and early 2000s when purses kind of became a punchline, like Matt LeBlanc's character and friends, famously has this leather bag and they make fun of him for it. Okay. And then in the show Seinfeld, Jerry Seinfeld ditches his overstuffed wallet for a shoulder bag. And then in the 2009 comedy The Hangover, Zach Galfanakas sports a brown cross-body bag, much to the chagrin of his buddies. So they got made fun of a little bit. It feels like this episode falls in that time period of the 90s, early 2000s.
在90年代和2000年代初，钱包有点像是一个笑点，比如《老友记》中马特·勒布朗饰演的角色，标志性地背着这个皮包，他们为此取笑他。好吧。然后在电视剧《宋飞正传》中，杰瑞·宋飞扔掉了他那塞得满满的钱包，换成了一个单肩包。然后在2009年的喜剧电影《宿醉》中，扎克·加利费安纳基斯背着一个棕色的跨肩包，这让他的死党们懊恼不已。所以他们多少被嘲笑了一下。感觉这一集就落在了90年代、2000年代初的那个时期。
But then in 2018, Vogue Business says there was a debut of sporty cross-body bags from Gucci and Supreme. And all of a sudden, you saw these celebrities and athletes using them. And it really blew this up. And then I read on a website called Glossy in August of 2024 that searches for men's cross-body and carry-all bags has gone up. Are you ready for this? Okay. 900% Wow.
但到了2018年，《Vogue Business》表示，古驰和Supreme推出了运动风格的斜挎包。突然之间，你看到这些名人和运动员们都在使用它们。这真的让它大火了一把。然后我在2024年8月一个叫做Glossy的网站上看到，搜索男士斜挎包和全能包的搜索量上升了。你们准备好听这个了吗？好吧。900% 哇。
Yeah. I also read on several different websites where they asked men about carrying types of bags and cross-body bags and they had one common theme. They all like the functionality of it. A few mentioned that trying to fit all of their items into their pockets made their pants uncomfortable and bulky. Mm-hmm. That makes sense to me. And now with athletes carrying these bags on game days and celebrities, are carrying them on red carpets, men's bags are really taking off.
是的。我还从几个不同的网站上看到，他们询问了男士们背哪种类型的包以及斜挎包，他们有一个共同点。他们都喜欢它的实用性。少数人提到，试图把所有物品塞进口袋里会让他们的裤子穿起来很不舒服而且显得臃肿。嗯-hmm。这对我来说说得通。现在随着运动员们在比赛日背着这些包，名人们在红毯上也背着它们，男士包包真的开始流行起来了。
But this is like 20 years later. Yes. At this time. At this time, when this episode was written, it was very much still in the zeitgeist to make fun of it, to call it a MERS, a man purse. But that is not the case anymore. But men's purses are nothing new. Men have been carrying like these girdle pouch things for a long time. Hmm. So there you go. I say go get your bag if you want a bag.
但这已经是20年后的事了。是的。在当时。在这一集被写出来的那个时候，嘲笑它、把它叫做MERS（男士手包）依然非常符合当时的时代精神。但现在情况已经不是这样了。不过男士手包并不是什么新鲜事。男士们背这种束腹袋一样的东西已经很久了。嗯。所以就是这样。我说如果你想要个包，就去买个包吧。
I just want bigger pockets. I actually want to put everything in my pockets. Well, I don't want a purse. You don't want a purse. You want bigger pockets. But for people who want more than just what can fit in your pocket, go get your bag. Yeah. I guess so. Well, Dwight's going to take Jim's advice. He's going to go in and he's going to buy a purse from Katie. And then Jim is going to run over to Pam's desk and they're going to do that little thing you do where you like make up dialogue. Flirty flirt, flirt. As they're watching him through the window, they're like, oh, look, I love this. This is wonderful. They're doing that little thing.
我只是想要更大的口袋。其实我想把所有东西都塞进口袋里。好吧，我可不要钱包。你不要钱包。你想要更大的口袋。但对于那些想要的不止是能塞进口袋里的人来说，去买个包吧。对。我想也是。好吧，德怀特打算听从吉姆的建议。他要走进去，从凯蒂那里买一个钱包。然后吉姆要跑到帕姆的办公桌前，他们要做那个你们常做的小动作，就是编造对话。调情，调情，调情。当他们透过窗户看着他时，他们会想，哦，看啊，我喜欢这个。这太棒了。他们在做那个小动作。
I actually brought up part of this scene in my All About Michael Scott because it's when we find out that Michael's cell phone ring at this time is Mambo number five. Yes, this was added in the super fan episode, this flirty moment at reception with Jim and Pam is expanded. And this is when Pam tells Jim that Michael has been talking to Katie as well. Yeah. And the shot from our opening credits was taken from this scene. Oh, yeah. Of Jim and Pam at reception.
我实际上在我的“关于迈克尔·斯科特”节目中提到了这场戏的一部分，因为正是在这里我们发现迈克尔此时手机铃声是《曼波第五号》。是的，这是在粉丝特别版中添加的内容，吉姆和帕姆在前台的这段调情时刻被扩写了。正是在这里，帕姆告诉吉姆，迈克尔也一直在和凯蒂聊天。对。而我们片头字幕里的那个镜头就是从这场戏里截取的。哦，对。吉姆和帕姆在前台的镜头。
That's from this moment of them watching Dwight in the conference room. I also want to note that there's this moment in this scene when Pam mentions that his cell phone ringtone is still Mambo number five. we kind of cut to Michael in his office. It's at 15 minutes, 34 seconds, and you can really tell that that is real sunlight coming through the window, that that is not faky window that this is from the real building. Because we're in the real building. Yep. Well, now Katie is showing Pam a cute purse and Michael interrupts them and he does the Michael Snark thing again. He says to Pam, I'm sorry, are you on your lunch break or was that earlier?
那是他们看着德怀特在会议室里的那一幕。我还想指出的是，在这场戏里有一个时刻，帕姆提到他的手机铃声仍然是《曼波第五号》。我们镜头切到了迈克尔在他的办公室里。那是15分34秒，你真的能看出那是透过窗户照进来的真实阳光，那不是假的窗户，这是在真实的建筑里拍的。因为我们在真的建筑里。Yep。好吧，现在凯蒂正在向帕姆展示一个漂亮的钱包，迈克尔打断了他们，他又做出了迈克尔式的刻薄举动。他对帕姆说，不好意思，你是在吃午休，还是刚才已经吃过了？
Yeah. Busted. So she leaves and as she's leaving, Katie goes, come back. Was that scripted or improvised? I looked it up. It was improvised. I had a feeling. It was just really funny.
是的。被抓包了。所以她离开了，在她离开的时候，凯蒂说，回来。那是剧本里的还是即兴发挥的？我查了一下。那是即兴发挥的。我有这种感觉。这真的很有趣。
Well, now Michael tells Katie, I got to show you something. Come to my office. He bought the flipping Starbucks digital barista for $1,000. Yes. And he has a talking head where he says, coffee is the great incentivizer. Really speeds people up. He says it's not the only drug that does that back in the 80s before they knew how bad cocaine was for you, Dundra Mifflin. Man, they could really move some paper.
好吧，现在迈克尔告诉凯蒂，我得让你看个东西。来我办公室。他花了1000美元买了那个该死的星巴克数码咖啡机。是的。他有一个独白镜头，里面说，咖啡是伟大的激励工具。真的能让人做事效率加倍。他说这不是唯一能做到这一点的毒品，在80年代人们还不知道可卡因对你有多大危害之前，邓德·米夫林。天哪，他们卖起纸来真是不含糊。
That made me laugh. I thought that was funny. Katie is going to get a text and she looks really bummed because her ride has bailed on her. Who is her ride? Why doesn't Katie have a car? I know. Someone dropped her off at this business park. And she didn't know anyone there.
这让我笑了。我觉得这挺搞笑的。凯蒂收到了一条短信，她看起来非常沮丧，因为她的顺风车放了她鸽子。谁是她的顺风车？为什么凯蒂没有车？我知道。有人把她放在了这个商业园区。而她在那儿谁也不认识。
They just dropped her off. I mean, we talked about this before. All day she needed to be in the conference room. How long does it take to sell purses to 16 people? I mean. And who dropped her off? And why won't they come pick her up? Well, I don't know.
他们就把她放在那儿。我的意思是，我们之前讨论过。她一整天都需要待在会议室里。向16个人推销钱包要花多长时间？我的意思是。而且是谁把她送来的？为什么他们不来接她？好吧，我不知道。
They're not going to. But Michael is going to insist on driving her home. She reluctantly agrees. And now we get this amazing new Michael talking head, where Michael is just talking about why women find him attractive. It is so all over the place. It's brilliant. I thought we should hear it.
他们不会来了。但迈克尔坚持要开车送她回家。她不情愿地同意了。现在我们看到了这个令人惊叹的全新的迈克尔独白，迈克尔在其中大谈女人们为什么会觉得他有吸引力。这简直太天马行空了。太精彩了。我觉得我们应该听听。
Why do women find Michael Scott attractive? Why are women appealed to Michael Scott? I guess because I'm an authority figure because I have a lot of power. Women are attracted to that. That's appealing to women. I think I'm a little bit of a bad boy. They're a little mystery to me.
为什么女人们会觉得迈克尔·斯科特有吸引力？为什么女性会被迈克尔·斯科特吸引？我猜因为我是个权威人物，因为我拥有很大的权力。女性会被这一点吸引。这对女性很有吸引力。我觉得我多少有点坏男孩气质。她们对我有点神秘感。
I don't just lay it all out there. You know, you have to hold something back. I don't think I'm too shabby to look at. I wouldn't kick me out of bed for eating crackers. But I guess I think my comedy really is the, is the topper. That's the way to get in, you know? I think that's really what's saying.
我不会把所有底牌都亮出来。你知道的，你必须有所保留。我觉得我的外表也不算太差劲。我不会因为吃饼干就把我赶下床的。但我猜我觉得我的喜剧效果才是最绝的。那是切入正题的方法，你知道吗？我觉得那才是真正的杀手锏。
Once they're laughing, that's, once they're laughing, that's 50% of them being horizontal. So not that I'm just, not that that's my, that's what I'm trying to do. But I think it helps. Kind of melts the ice. Brinks the ice. breaks the ice and melts them melts their hearts.
一旦她们笑了，那，一旦她们笑了，她们有50%的可能就会横着躺下了。倒不是说我只是，倒不是说那就是我的，那就是我想要做的事。但我觉得它有帮助。有点像破冰。带来破冰。破冰并融化她们，融化她们的心。
I feel like Michael Scott could be on our episode today. I know. With all these phrases that he's coining. I know. I looked in the script. This talking head is not in it. Nope. It is not in our candy bag alt.
我觉得迈克尔·斯科特今天可以上我们的节目了。我知道。带着他创造的所有这些新词。我知道。我在剧本里查过了。这段独白不在剧本里。没有。它不在我们的糖果袋备选片段里。
Nope. I really think that this was just Steve improvising. Just riffing. They just let the camera roll. I loved it. I also did catch the boom. Really? All right.
没有。我真的认为这只是史蒂夫的即兴发挥。纯粹是即兴发挥。他们只是让摄像机一直开着。我很喜欢。我还捕捉到了收音话筒杆。真的吗？好吧。
Little boom shadow. Boom shadow. That was what we would sing on set. Dwight is now drinking his coffee with his brand new purse. This is a new scene that's in the superfan episode. Jim tells him, you know what, you should put some stuff in your purse because if she's looking, you want to make sure it looks like you're using it, right? So Dwight looks over at Katie and then starts shoving things into his purse.
小小的收音话筒杆阴影。话筒杆阴影。那是我们在片场常唱的歌。德怀特现在正拿着他崭新的钱包喝咖啡。这是粉丝特别版里新增的一场戏。吉姆告诉他，你知道吗，你应在你的钱包里放点东西，因为如果她在看，你要确保看起来你真的在用它，对吧？于是德怀特看了看凯蒂，然后开始把东西往钱包里塞。
19 minutes, 24 seconds. Dwight is drinking coffee, as you mentioned, out of a football mug. Yes. But not a team mug. It's just a mug with a football on it that says football. I noticed this mug a few times in season one. It is the weirdest mug. I feel like if you could recreate this mug for someone, it would make an excellent deep cut gift for an office fan.
19分24秒。正如你所提到的，德怀特正用一个橄榄球马克杯喝咖啡。是的。但不是球队的杯子。它只是一个印有橄榄球图案并写着“football”的杯子。我在第一季里注意到过好几次这个杯子。这是最奇怪的杯子。我觉得如果你能为某人复制这个杯子，它会成为送给办公室迷的一份绝佳的冷门礼物。
Oh, yeah. Also, there is so much background activity. in this scene. Meredith is at the supply shelf. Stanley walks in and sits down. We all got up from our desks in season one. It's hilarious to me. We were very busy. We were. Kevin is now taking a look at the purses. He's going to try to flirt with Katie by telling her he's in a Steve Miller tribute band. He says, do you like Steve Miller? She says no. But here, we have to do it for people because it's so funny. Okay, I'll be Kevin. Okay. Do you like Steve Miller? Miller? No. Because I'm in a Steve Miller tribute. Oh. I know. It's so good. It's so good. That was an extra
哦，是的。此外，这一幕中的背景活动也太多了。
scene for the super fan. Well, now Dwight and Michael are in Michael's office. They're looking at his computer. Lady, there's a moment here that I should have included in my Michael versus technology breakdown. It's so me. Oh my God. I'm just Michael Scott when it comes to my desktop. I just I need you to hear it. I should never have let the temp touches there. I had all these great icons, and now I have four folders. So it's actually better this way. No, it's not, because I could just click on the icon and then I'm on to.
迈克尔，我能问你个问题吗？他以前有所有的图标，现在却有四个文件夹。而且他根本不知道任何东西都在哪儿了。他不知道。是的。你知道我的桌面长什么样吗？我知道。我知道。
Michael, could I ask you something? He had all these icons, and now he has four folders. And he doesn't know where anything is anymore. He doesn't. Yeah. And you know what my desktop looks like? I do. I do.
我的看起来像四个文件夹。我的到处都是乱七八糟的。我知道。接下来在会议室里，斯坦利刚刚买了一个钱包。迈克尔给凯蒂拿来了一杯来自作为奖励奖品的咖啡机的意式浓缩咖啡。斯坦利说，等等，迈克尔。那不是应该作为顶级销售员的奖励吗？迈克尔说，它很好清洗。
Mine looks like four folders. Mine is like shit everywhere. I know. Next up in the conference room, Stanley has just purchased a purse. And Michael is going to bring Katie an espresso from the machine that is an incentive prize. And Stanley's like, wait a second, Michael. Isn't that meant to be the prize for the top salesman? And Michael's like, it cleans easily.
我能把它洗干净。现在我们要去厨房了。吉姆进来，向德怀特索要他的订书机。德怀特说它在我的钱包里。当然，每个人都轻笑了一声。好吧，我只是喜欢每个人都慢慢抬起头来做出反应，但德怀特甚至都没有转身。他只是在冰箱里翻找。是的。
I can clean it. Now we're going to go to the kitchen. Jim enters, asks Dwight for his stapler. Dwight says it's in my purse. Of course, everyone gets a little snicker. Well, I just love everyone just slowly looks up and reacts, but Dwight doesn't even turn around. He's just digging in the fridge. Yes.
同样的，附楼里背景中的走动实在是太多了。德文四处走动。每个人都在厨房里或者就在厨房后面。每个人都同时去往各个地方。确实如此。现在，迈克尔把帕姆叫进他的办公室。询问他的邮件情况，但他真正想知道的是她这个年纪的女孩对沙发床怎么看。我简直看不下去了。我的意思是，怎么可能看得下去？这太荒谬了。
Again, so much deep background movement back there in the annex. Devin is walking around. Everybody is in the kitchen or just behind the kitchen. Everybody just goes everywhere all at once. It's so true. Now, Michael is going to have Pam in his office. asking about his male, but what he really wants to know is how girls her age feel about futons. I couldn't get through this scene. I mean, how could you? It's so ridiculous.
另外，附楼后面有那么多深度的背景移动。德文在四处走动。每个人都在厨房里或厨房后面。所有人一下子到处都是。太真实了。现在，迈克尔要把帕姆叫到他的办公室，询问她的邮件，但他真正想知道的是她这个年纪的女孩对日式床垫有什么看法。我简直无法看完这一场戏。我是说，怎么可能看得下去？太荒谬了。
Every time he said futon. Whatever this relationship is with Katie is just so crazy. First of all, it's going to give her a thousand dollar coffee maker if she took it. Yep. Give her a ride home. I don't know what happens with the futons. Yes. Of course, Pam is going to go out and tell Jim all about this conversation. They're laughing about the futon when Roy comes in. He wants to make up with Pam. We talked about this last time. He's going to tickle her into forgiving him. Yes, we discussed my dislike for tickling. Also, if I were to do what I call a cringe meter for this episode, this one would be a nine on the cringe meter. This scene? Yeah. Poor Jim. I know. They're literally almost leaning on him laughing and tickle.
每次他说折叠床的时候。不管他和凯蒂的关系是什么样，都太疯狂了。首先，如果她收下的的话，他打算送她一个价值一千美元的咖啡机。没错。顺便送她回家。我不知道折叠床是怎么回事。是的。当然，帕姆会跑去把这段对话全都告诉吉姆。罗伊进来时，他们还在笑话折叠床的事。他想和帕姆重修旧好。我们上次讨论过这个。他打算用胳肢她的方式来求得她的原谅。是的，我们讨论过我有多讨厌别人胳肢我。另外，如果我要给这一集做一个所谓的尴尬指数评级的话，这一集在尴尬指数上可以打九分。这个场景？对。可怜的吉姆。我知道。他们几乎快要靠在他身上又笑又闹了。
Yeah. Cringe meter number nine. And then Pam has this talking head that says Jim's a great guy. He's like a brother to her. They're best friends. She really hopes he finds someone. Pam, maybe say it enough until you believe it. Yeah. Does she wish? I don't think so because he's going to find someone in a second. She's not all that happy about it. She's real sour about it. Well, Angela's in the conference room and she's looking at purses. And we talked a lot about this scene in our original breakdown. Yes, all of our dialogue between Angela and Katie's improvising the scene. We had a lot of fun. You can tell. Thank you. You guys were good together. Thank you. I actually think there's a spinoff with you, me and Amy, just like an improv show because that scene at the top was so good. Yeah. Purse girls. Come see us every Thursday night, 9 p.m. Oh, that's too late. Too late. Sorry. It's $35 to drink minimum. There is no parking. Starts at four. Dwight is watching Angela and Katie through the window and he is going to get up his nerve to go in and ask her out. But she turns him down.
对。尴尬指数九分。然后帕姆有个单人访谈，说吉姆是个很好的人。他就像她的兄弟一样。他们是最好的朋友。她真心希望他能找到某个人。帕姆，也许你要不停地说，直到连你自己也相信为止？对。她真的希望如此吗？我不觉得，因为他马上就要找到某个人了。对此她可一点都不高兴。她心里酸溜溜的。好吧，安吉拉在会议室里看钱包。我们在最初的复盘中花了很多时间讨论这个场景。是的，安吉拉和凯蒂之间的所有对话都是即兴发挥的。我们玩得很开心。看得出来。谢谢。你们俩配合得很好。谢谢。我甚至觉得你可以、我和艾米可以搞个衍生剧，就像即兴喜剧秀一样，因为开头那个场景太棒了。对。卖钱包的女孩。每周四晚上九点来看我们。哦，太晚了。太晚了。抱歉。有35美元的最低消费。而且没有停车位。四点开始。德怀特透过窗户看着安吉拉和凯蒂，他正鼓起勇气进去约她。但她拒绝了他。
She's pretty harsh. I was like, oh, made me sad. We are now going to have a Dwight talking head. It's a pretty famous Dwight talking head. He outlines what his idea of a perfect date is. Yes, of course, there's ninjas, there's knives, there's blood. There's poison, but he knew about it all along, guys. She was in on it all along.
她挺严厉的。当时我想，哦，真让人难过。接下来我们要看一个德怀特单人访谈。这是一个相当著名的德怀特单人访谈。他勾勒了他心目中的完美约会有多完美。是的，当然，有忍者，有刀具，有血。还有毒药，但他一直都知道，伙计们。她从一开始就参与其中了。
But he knew. Oh, right. He knew she was in on it. That's right. Luan crosses twice in the background of this talking head. Creed crosses. Devin. Then at the end, Creed again.
但他知道。哦，对了。他知道了她参与其中。没错。在这段单人访谈的背景中，露安两次走过。克里德走过。德文。然后最后，克里德又走了一次。
I was just like, there's so much crossing. Also, what's really hilarious is that both Creed and Luan cross into the accounting nook by your desk, Angela, which means that they would cross there and just stand there and then come out. And cross right back. But where do they, they must have just been standing in the corner. I don't know why they're crossing to accounting. I'm in the conference room. You're with Katie trying to buy a purse.
我当时就觉得，怎么有这么多人走来走去。还有，超级搞笑的是，克里德和露安都走进了你办公桌旁边的会计角，安吉拉，这意味着他们会走到那里，站在那儿，然后再出来。然后又走回去。但他们去哪儿了，他们肯定只是站在角落里。我不知道他们为什么往会计部走。我在会议室。你正和凯蒂一起挑钱包。
Yeah. What are they doing at your desk? They're messing with your stuff. They're snooping around. Oh dear. Now Michael is going to ask Ryan for some help cleaning out his car. This is one of my favorite scenes. It's one of my favorite scenes of the whole series.
对。他们在你的办公桌前干什么？他们在动你的东西。他们在翻箱倒柜。天哪。现在迈克尔要找瑞安帮忙清理他的车。这是我最喜欢的场景之一。这是整部剧里我最喜欢的场景之一。
Blue blast. Blue is not a flavor. No. All of it. Oh, and he wants the Arctic Blast and the passenger side cup holder. Yeah. That's ready for you, Katie. This is what you're missing. I know. You don't get the convertible. You don't get the Arctic blast. You don't get the coffee maker. 25 minutes and eight seconds. Faky water bottle label and then faky blue blast label. Faky labels. Faky labels. She's tracking it. She's tracking that and who's crossing where. I am. Well, now Jim is going to go into the conference room. And what is smooth operator? Okay, Jenna F from Los Angeles wants to know how much of this was improv?
蓝色爆裂。蓝色根本不是一种口味。没有。全都要。哦，他还要副驾驶座位上的杯架里放一个北极爆裂。对。这下给你准备好了，凯蒂。这就是你所错过的。我知道。你没有敞篷车。你没有北极爆裂。你也没有咖啡机。25分08秒。山寨的水瓶标签，还有山寨的蓝色爆裂标签。山寨标签。山寨标签。她连这个都在观察。她连那个和谁从哪里走过都在观察。我确实在观察。好吧，现在吉姆要进会议室了。什么是“情场高手”？好吧，来自洛杉矶的珍娜·F想知道这里面有多少是即兴发挥的？
Oh, I will tell you. Per the shooting draft, this is what was scripted. Jim approaches Katie. It says he sidles up to her. He says, hi, I'm Jim. Katie says hi. The rest is improv. What?
哦，我来告诉你们。根据拍摄剧本，原本写的是这样的。吉姆走向凯蒂。上面写着他悄悄走到她身边。他说，嗨，我是吉姆。凯蒂说嗨。剩下的全是即兴发挥。什么？
The rest is improv until it gets to the part where he says, don't try to sell me anything. I just want to learn. Everything else is improv. This is improv. I'm Katie. Well, hi, Katie. Nice to meet you. You sit out there, don't you? I do. It's what I'm best known for sitting out there. All right. Let's talk about purses. But just talk to me. Seriously, that was all improvised. Wow. Mm-hmm. So good. So good. Jim is very smooth when he wants to be, huh? Did he flip the charm switch or what? He waited until the end of the day. Everybody was coming at her all day. He played it so cool. Yeah. We're going to go back to Michael's car.
剩下的都是即兴发挥，直到他说“别试图向我推销任何东西，我只是来学习的”那部分。其他全是即兴发挥。这都是即兴的。我是凯蒂。噢，嗨，凯蒂。很高兴认识你。你坐外面，对吧？我是。坐在外面是我最擅长的。好吧。我们来聊聊钱包。不过只要跟我聊就行。说真的，那全都是即兴发挥。哇。嗯哼。太棒了。太棒了。吉姆想耍帅的时候真的很会耍帅，对吧？他是什么时候按下的魅力开关？他一直等到快下班。整整一天所有人都围着她转。他表现得太酷了。对。我们回过头来看迈克尔的车。
And I love this. This is the scene where he finds all the filet of fish wrappers. The smell alike. How many filial fishes do you eat? And Michael is like, that's from a couple of months. It's like still. Ryan goes still. And then this is where we find out about his smell alike cologne.
我喜欢这个。这是他找到所有菲力鱼汉堡包装纸的场景。味道都一样。你到底吃了多少个菲力鱼汉堡？迈克尔却说，那是几个月里积攒的。瑞安说，还是有很多。然后这就是我们发现他的同味古龙水的地方。
Yes. That Ryan's like it's empty. In the straw. The soup still in the straw. How many times? have you done that? I know. You like pull it out and you wrote, I've done this so many times. Now he can throw it away. Now he can. But now this scene is expanded and Michael is going to ask Ryan to hook him up with some great music to play. I love this scene. I have talked about it. He wants Ryan's recommendations
对。瑞安说它都空了。吸管里。汤还在吸管里。你到底干过多少次这种事？我知道。你把它拔出来，然后你写道，“我干过好多次这种事了”。现在他可以把它扔掉了。现在可以了。不过现在这个场景扩充了，迈克尔要让瑞安给他找点好听的音乐来放。我太喜欢这个场景了。我聊过好多次了。他想要瑞安的推荐
and Ryan says do you like hip hop, indie rock, the strokes, the hives, the fleables. Oh, Michael's like yes to the fleables. Yeah. The glorbs loves them. Glorps loves them. While they're having this conversation at 26 minutes and 59 seconds, there is this angle on the parking lot and there is this brick wall behind the car. And, you know, this is because this was a real parking lot at a real building. But once we move locations, you will never see this brick wall again. And I thought it was interesting that we didn't try to recreate that. The brick wall? Yeah. We let it go. We let it go. We were like, I mean, I guess I'm not surprised because what we're. Were we going to build a brick wall?
然后瑞安说你喜欢嘻哈、独立摇滚、鼓击乐队、蜂巢乐队、飞盘乐队。哦，迈克尔说喜欢飞盘乐队。对。怪兽乐队很喜欢他们。怪兽乐队喜欢他们。当他们在26分59秒进行这段对话时，镜头拍到了停车场，车后面有一堵砖墙。而且，你知道，这是因为这是真建筑里的真停车场。但一旦我们搬了外景地，你就再也看不到这堵砖墙了。我觉得有趣的是，我们居然没有试图去还原它。砖墙？对。我们就让它过去了。我们就让它过去了。我们当时想，我的意思是，我想我并不感到惊讶，因为我们在做什么。难道我们要去砌一堵砖墙吗？
But I don't know. Brick wall. Well, I want you to know that there was a Ryan talking head that would have come right after this scene. It's in the shooting draft. It's not in deleted scenes. It did not make it into the super fan episode. And it read simply like this. Ryan has a smug look on his face.
但我不知道。砖墙。好吧，我想让你们知道，本来在这个场景之后还有一个瑞安的单人访谈。它在拍摄剧本里。它不在删减片段里。它没有被剪进超级粉丝版剧集里。它的内容很简单，是这样的。瑞安脸上露出了自鸣得意的表情。
He looks to Cameron says, Michael's really into indie rock. He's into bands I've never even heard of. And then he laughs. Well, now. Pam is hanging out at Jim's desk. She's bored. She's like, what are you doing for the weekend? I'll tell you what he's doing this weekend. It's going out with Katie. He sure is. Oh, Pam's face. Oh, Pam's face. And guess what she's going to do? Yeah. She's going to help Roy's cousin move. Oh, the romance. Yeah, she has this line where she says, we're going to help Roy's
他看着卡梅伦说，迈克尔真的很喜欢独立摇滚。他喜欢的乐队我甚至都没听说过。然后他笑了。好吧，现在。帕姆在吉姆的办公桌旁闲逛。她很无聊。她问，你周末打算干嘛？我来告诉你他这个周末要干嘛。他要和凯蒂出去约会。他当然是。哦，帕姆的表情。哦，帕姆的表情。你猜她要干嘛？对。她要去帮罗伊的表弟搬家。哦，这浪漫呐。对，她有这样一句台词，她说，我们要去帮罗伊的
cousin move because Roy's got a truck. Well, this made me laugh because when Lee and I started dating, he said he always had to help people move because he had a Zuzu trooper. He was like, he was the guy with the big car. He was. He's like, it's a real thing. Yeah. It's a real thing. The person with the big car. It's true. I do remember that. I had a friend with a truck and he moved everybody. Exactly. It's so true. Well, I want to point out when Sam sort of sadly walks back to reception, there is no plant. Oh. There's no plan at reception.
表弟搬家，因为罗伊有辆卡车。这让我笑了，因为我和李刚开始约会时，他说他总是得帮别人搬家，因为他有一辆五十铃微型卡车。他当时说，他就是那个开大车的家伙。他确实是。他说，这是真事。对。这是真事。开大车的那个人。确实如此。我确实记得那个。我有个朋友有辆卡车，他帮所有人都搬过家。一点没错。真的太真实了。好吧，我想指出的是，当帕姆有些伤心地走回前台时，那里没有植物。哦。前台没有植物。
No, there's not. Well, now Michael's going to have another talking head where he's talking again about being a ladies man. Wait, I love this talking head so much, lady, because this is part of this runner of Michael's desktop being messed up by Ryan. Ryan has only tried to help him clean up his computer. But now, guess what, he can't find. Can't find maps. Can't find maps. And this has now been woven into the superfan version of this talking head.
没有，确实没有。好吧，现在迈克尔又有了一个单人访谈，他在里面又谈到了自己是个情圣。等等，我太喜欢这个单人访谈了，女士，因为这是迈克尔的电脑桌面被瑞安搞砸这个梗的一部分。瑞安只是想帮他清理电脑。但现在，你猜怎么着，他找不到了。找不到地图了。现在这个情节已经被编进了这个单人访谈的超级粉丝版里。
I think we should hear it. I think in order to be a ladies man, it's imperative that people don't know you're a ladies man. So I kind of play that close to the chest. Ryan, where are my maps? You know, you don't like to flaunt it. Where do I go to get maps? I mean, but it's not like I'm showing off. Ryan, what did you do to my computer?
我觉得我们应该听听。我认为要想成为一个情圣，至关重要的一点是不能让别人知道你是个情圣。所以我对这一点保密得比较好。瑞安，我的地图在哪儿？你知道的，你不会到处炫耀。我上哪儿去找地图？我的意思是，但我也不是在显摆。瑞安，你对我的电脑做了什么？
I'm supposed to have maps, right? But where? They see me as a, as a, as a big. powerful businessman here. Kind of swaggeres around a little bit. It's really not even fair. I don't know. What can I say? Women are attracted to power.
我应该有地图的，对吧？但是在哪儿呢？他们把我当成一个，一个，一个在这儿很有权势的商人。走路时还有点趾高气扬的。这真的太不公平了。我不知道。我能说什么呢？女人就是会被权力吸引。
And I think other people have told me I have a very symmetrical face. I don't know. I don't know. Maybe they're right. I don't know. I just love it so much. First of all, I love it in any kind of show or writing that you get to like watch
而且我想其他人也跟我说过，我的脸非常对称。我不知道。我不知道。也许他们是对的。我不知道。我太喜欢这个了。首先，我喜欢任何那种你可以看着一个人
when there are two things happening to a person. So it's like he's trying to talk about what a great catch he is. But at the same time, he's like, where are my maps? He's getting so irritated. Well, now it's the end of the day. And here's that moment. I said Dwight goes over and gives Kelly his mini briefcase purse. And then Pam is going to apply lip gloss kind of shyly. And then the cameraman catches it and she's embarrassed. That's cringe factor 10. I so remembered doing. this scene and have you ever like had this happen before? I feel like I have this stored in my body from my youth or something where like you know you're going to see maybe a cute boy that you like
同时发生两件事的剧集或剧本。就好像他在努力谈论自己是个多好的择偶对象。但与此同时，他在想，我的地图去哪儿了？他变得越来越暴躁。好吧，现在是一天结束的时候了。这就是那个时刻。我说了德怀特走过去把他的迷你公文包钱包给了凯莉。然后帕姆有些羞涩地涂了点唇彩。接着摄像师拍到了这一幕，她很尴尬。这就是尴尬指数10分。我太记得拍这个场景了，你们有没有过这样的经历？我觉得我的青春期身体里好像储存了这种记忆什么的，就是你知道你可能会见到一个你喜欢的可爱男孩
and so you put on a lipstick. Yeah. Or you put on mascara. You do something. You do something. And then to just kind of like get noticed. But then when you see yourself in the mirror, you're realize how it's just like too much and then you feel like all cringy inside. Yeah, you don't feel like you're real version of yourself. Yes. You were trying to not be you. Yes. Yes. We've all done it. Yes. Well, now everyone's leaving for the day. It's dark out. Everyone's walking to their cars at the same time. Michael's walking out with Katie and Jim. And this is when we find out that Jim is just going to give Katie a ride home after they get drinks. Yeah. And Michael's like, oh, yeah, yeah. Mm-hmm. As they're walking out. Did you hear Katie's line, which I think has to be an improv by Amy?
然后你就会涂上口红。对。或者你涂上睫毛膏。你会做点什么。你会做点什么。然后就是为了引起注意。但当你从镜子里看到自己时，你意识到这实在是太夸张了，然后你心里就会感到一阵尴尬。对，你会觉得自己不像真实的自己。是的。你当时在努力克制自己不要表现得像平时那样。是的。是的。我们都干过。是的。好吧，现在大家都下班要走了。天黑了。所有人都在同一时间走向他们的车。迈克尔和凯蒂还有吉姆一起走了出去。就在这时，我们发现吉姆打算在他们喝完酒后顺便送凯蒂回家。对。迈克尔就说，哦，对，对。嗯哼。就在他们往外走的时候。你听到凯蒂的那句台词了吗，我觉得那肯定是艾米即兴发挥的？
What, what? She goes, everyone's like, good night, good night. She goes, good night. It was nice to meet some of you. That's very funny. She was so good as Katie. Well, Jim is going to open the door for his corolla for Katie. This is more of smooth Jim. Oh, so charming. And Pam is going to sadly watch from the window of Roy's truck. Yes, the truck that we talked about the first time that David Denman and I got left in when the entire production wrapped for the day. We were still sitting there waiting to do another take.
什么，什么？她说，大家都在说，晚安，晚安。她说，晚安。很高兴认识你们中的一些人。太搞笑了。她演凯蒂演得真好。好吧，吉姆为凯蒂打开了他卡罗拉的车门。这更是情场高手吉姆的作风。哦，太有魅力了。而帕姆则难过地从罗伊的卡车车窗里看着这一切。是的，就是我们第一次谈到的那辆卡车，当时整场拍摄收工时，我和大卫·丹曼被留在了车里。我们当时还坐在那儿等着拍下一个镜头。
But he's good company, so if you're going to be stuck somewhere. But the superfan episode does not end there. We end now with a Michael talking head. He is still talking about his American Way magazines. He says, did you know that when Doris Roberts is in Phoenix, she likes to eat it harder? She loves barbecue. Who knew? Yeah.
但他是个很好的聊天对象，所以如果非得被困在什么地方的话。不过超级粉丝版的剧集并没有到此结束。我们最后以迈克尔的一个单人访谈收尾。他还在谈论他的《美国道路》杂志。他说，你知道吗，当多丽丝·罗伯茨在菲尼克斯时，她喜欢吃得更硬朗一点？她喜欢烧烤。谁能想到呢？对。
He also read a profile on Corbyn Burson. And he learned that he used to play Little League. Yeah. He also read a profile on Bronson Pinchot and his adventures in Tuscany that was very charming. He also read profiles on red buttons. Yeah. He really loves that magazine, guys. He loves it.
他还读了一篇关于科尔宾·伯森的人物专访。他了解到科尔宾以前打过少儿棒球。对。他还读了一篇关于布朗森·平肖及其托斯卡纳历险记的人物专访，非常迷人。他还读了关于雷德·巴顿的人物专访。对。他是真的很喜欢那本杂志，伙计们。他是真喜欢。
Well, everyone, that was the super fan episode of Hot Girl. I really loved rewatching it with all that extra footage. I really did. I know. I can't believe I'm saying this, but I think I want to watch the whole series again now. I mean, I know all of you listening have watched it so many times all the way through, but I want to do it again. Well, I feel the same way. I liked going back.
好了，各位，这就是《辣妹》的超级粉丝版剧集。能带着所有那些额外的素材重新看一遍，我真的很喜欢。我是说真的。我知道。不敢相信我会这么说，但我想我接下来想把整部剧再看一遍。我的意思是，我知道所有在听节目的你们都已经从头到尾看过很多遍了，但我还是想再看一遍。好吧，我的感觉也一样。我很喜欢回顾过去。
So listen, if there are. any more superfan episodes that are some of your very favorites, let us know, write to us in Dear Office Ladies. We want to know which superfan episodes or just which episodes do you love the most. We will rewatch them. And now Office Lady 6.0 is going to start its holiday break, but don't worry, second drink will continue through the holidays on Mondays. So you all have a safe and happy holidays. Please know how much we appreciate you. And we'll see you in 2025. And if you take nothing else from this episode, just remember the moral of the story is that if two things look the same, that doesn't mean that they are. And you know what?
所以听着，如果还有任何其他你们最喜欢的超级粉丝版剧集，请告诉我们，写信给我们“办公室女士”邮箱。我们想知道你们最喜欢哪些超级粉丝版剧集，或者仅仅是最喜欢哪些剧集。我们会重新看它们的。现在《办公室女士》6.0版要开始放假了，但别担心，假期期间星期一的“第二杯”节目照常进行。祝大家度过一个安全快乐的假期。请知道我们是多么感激你们。我们2025年见。如果你从这一集中没能学到别的什么，只要记住这个故事的寓意：如果两样东西看起来一样，并不意味着它们就是一样的。你知道吗？
If all else fails, blow it out the window. We'll see you next year. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman
如果所有办法都失效了，那就把它抛诸脑后吧。我们明年见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛公司的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。奥德赛公司的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼
and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。